Tim Ferriss: Should we kick this party off?
What do you think? So first of all, cheers.
Derek Sivers: Thanks to Matt.
Tim Ferriss: Matt Mullenweg. Thank you for the
Scotch blend, which we shall enjoy
here. So I’ll take a sip first.
Derek Sivers: Ooh.
Tim Ferriss:
We have Scotch. We have Go Go Goa Black
tea. I have a backup of Diet Coke in case
this is podcaster speed ball. So I expect
this is going to be a fantastic episode.
For those who are not watching or those who
may not have video in front of them, we have
two different sized Scotch glasses. If you were to
walk into Derek’s kitchen, you would find a wide
assortment of glasses, namely one other glass.
There are only three glasses. It’s like a Russian
nesting doll of three separate glasses. And those
are the only glasses you have in the house.
Derek Sivers: Yeah. And I
didn’t buy any of them.
Tim Ferriss: Explain. Because you walk the
talk of certain types of minimalism. There
are those out there who may not believe, or have
a healthy skepticism. And I’m telling you guys,
he’s got three glasses in his kitchen.
Derek Sivers: And this is my only pair of pants.
These three glasses, I don’t even think about
it because I just think about having enough.
There’s only me and my kid here. You come over
and you say, "Okay, let’s make some Scotch." And
you’re like, “Do you have any glasses?”
I was like, “No, that’s all I've got.”
I just have these glasses. And honestly,
I don’t even know where they came from.
But they work, They work and this is
enough. And these little bamboo cups
I got for my kid so that he wouldn’t break them.
Tim Ferriss: We will come back to this, because as
a foreshadowing for people who are listening, if
you have not read The Paradox of Choice by Barry
Schwartz, he talks about maximizers and
satisficers. So I think we’ll probably come back
to this in a bunch of different ways. But suffice
to say you are the embodiment of minimalism.
You also have two very nice suits that act
as your sort of outside in the world attire.
Derek Sivers: Again, it’s this idea of enough. At
home I wear junk, basically pajamas. The big baggy
t-shirt that somebody handed you at a conference
and you would never wear that outside the house.
Michael Browne in London: When I lived
in London right before COVID hit, I
thought I’m living here by Savile Row
in London. I’m about to leave England
forever. So I’m going to get a custom-made suit.
So I looked at Sartorial Talks — an interesting
YouTube channel diving deep into like the
the craft of fine clothing. Tailoring. And
he recommended Michael Browne in London.
So I went to Michael Browne and he said,
“What would you like?”
I said, “You’re the
expert. You know, just dress me.”
So he told me what to wear and I do.
Tim Ferriss: I have a little
bit more context here.
He would ask, “So what type of
shoes are you going to wear?”
And you’re like, “What should I wear?”
He’d say, “How are you thinking about X?”
And you’d be like, “How should
I be thinking about X?”
And this is something I’ve thought more and more
about, which is it’s not so much quantity versus
quality because there’s a whole spectrum,
right? You can have things that are very good
and you have half a dozen of them. Of course,
you can have one thing that is the best
subjectively or objectively, and that’s
it. You have one, or you could have a ton
of things and not care about this thing. So
this is a disposable item or service or fill
in the blank in my mind. So I think I think
we’ll we’ll probably talk more about this.
But what comes to mind for me also when I
think about, say, your suits, they’re great
suits. You’re happy with them, you look good
in them. And I think about, in contrast, my
accumulation of ill-fitting suits, in part
because my body weight has fluctuated so
much in my life. Right? I’ve gone from 145 to
220 in both cases being pretty lean. So I have
like kind of fat boy Tim jacket and then I’ve got
like really, really skinny, emaciated Tim jacket
and then I’ve got things in between. But I don’t
need most of those and yet I still have them.
Kevin Kelly in his new book, called Excellent
Advice for Living, said, “You know how you
have that bad pen? Throw out the bad pen.”
Derek Sivers: It’s so liberating. Don’t have the
bad pen. It’s about self-respect, isn’t it? Even
something as simple as a pen. When I’ve done that,
I went, “I’m better than this. I’m not
going to take this. This pen is not going
to rule over me any longer.”
Tim Ferriss: You’re only as
good as the worst pen in your house.
So let’s let’s start with with the story.
And I have not heard this story because you began
telling me and I said, “No, I don’t want to hear
it. Let’s save it.”
Scuba diving.
Derek Sivers: And what it taught
me about empathy and identity.
Tim Ferriss: I’ll listen to the TED Talk.
Derek Sivers: Oh, God. All right.
So. I was in Iceland and I never had
any intention to go scuba diving,
but I was at Thingvellir Park. If you’ve ever
been there where the two continental plates meet,
the American continental plate meets the Eurasian
continental plate, and there’s this deep fissure
in the ground, but it’s crystal clear water
so you can see all the way down. I was like,
“Ooh, I want to go in there.” It just looks
like Evian spring water, you know, poured
over rocks with nothing clouding the water.
I was in Iceland for a month, so I went to
take scuba diving lessons and the instructor
was great. The website is dive.is. And at the
time it was just him in his basement. And it was
me and one other guy learning scuba diving. So
we did the practice in the swimming
pool and we did all the theoretical
stuff. The swimming pool was great
and I loved the fact that it’s calm,
that you don’t need to panic about holding
your breath. It’s just slow and meditative.
But then the first time we went into the cold
ocean — and to be clear, I had to wear one of
those giant dry suits. Like you’re like a spaceman
with four layers of rubber and stuff over the
rubber. So it’s very claustrophobic. And then I
get into the water and it gets down to about 20m.
And I’m just like, “Oh, God, I hate this. I want
to go. I need to go. I need to, I just want to go
back at home. I want to be on the Internet.
I want to be emailing my friend. I want to
talk to my friend. I've got to get out of here.”
So I rapped on his tank and I went up to the top.
Tim Ferriss: You pointed to go up.
Derek Sivers: Yeah. And I tore off my
mask and I said, “I don’t want to. I’m just going
to go. You guys go ahead. I’m going to wait on the
side. There you go. Go ahead. I’ll just wait.”
And he was so sweet. He was so cool. He looked
at me and just stopped for a second and he said,
“Hold on a second. It’s a really nice day today.
Look around. Look at those mountains. See, it’s a
nice day today. Yeah, look. Look at what a look at
what a beautiful area we’re in right now. See?”
And then he said, “You know, if you were to
leave now, I know you’re flying back in seven
days. If I were to leave now, you wouldn’t be
able to complete the training and you wouldn’t
get your certification. I know you don’t want
that. Just relax for a second. It’s all right.”
And so I just relaxed for a second. You inflate
your BCD, so you’re just buoyant and you
float. And I went, "All right. Yeah." What
was I scared of? So, "Okay, I’m ready."
And so we go back down and I completed
it and it was great. It was no problem. And
I love being underwater. It’s wonderful.
That was the completion of my training. So
the next day was my first official dive. So
we’re there with a dozen other people that
have flown to Iceland from around the world,
including this couple from Germany that were
bragging about how many dives they’ve done.
“We’ve done over 100 dives.” They were acting
like know-it-alls. But then they’re like, “Oh,
dry suit, we’ve never done dry suit before.”
And so they’re getting into the dry suit.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it’s retro.
Yeah, it’s tough. It’s different.
Derek Sivers: And so I get underwater.
But this time I’m elated. I’m underwater
just where I wanted to be in that crystal clear
fissure there in Thingvellir, I was like, wow.
And at 20 meters down —
Tim Ferriss: Which is 60 feet. Pretty deep.
Derek Sivers: It’s the bottom of where
you’re supposed to go as a beginner.
And at the bottom I see the German
girl by herself and her partner is
not there. So I do the dive manners we
were taught, where I gave her the “OKAY?”
symbol and she gave the “NOT OKAY” symbol.
And I was like, “Oh, wait, am I mis-remembering?”
And I was like, “OKAY?” And again, she goes, “NOT
OKAY!” And I see her eyes are looking crazy.
And I thought, oh, shit, I’ve been trained for
this. Oh, my God. I can do this. Okay. I held
on to her BCD, held on to mine, inflated hers a
bit, asked if she needed my mouthpiece, and she
said no and helped her get up to the surface.
Up at the surface she rips her mask off just
like I did. She’s like, “I don’t like this!
I don’t like, no, this is not good! I don’t!
I hate this! I feel bad now! I want to go!”
And I just imitated the dive instructor exactly.
I said, “Well, hold on a second. Look around.
It’s a really nice day. Isn’t this great? You
see those mountains over there? Just relax
a second. I’m here with you. It’s okay.”
And so she calmed down and I saw her
do the same thing I did and calm down.
And then her boyfriend showed up.
Tim Ferriss: So where the hell was the boyfriend?
Derek Sivers: I don’t know. But he took her away.
Tim Ferriss: So, "You’re on your own,
babe. I’m out of here."
Derek Sivers: I’ve accidentally
missed one step in the storytelling
of this that I should have included.
The night in between those two days. I went home
that night thinking, “What the fuck? I think I
just had a panic attack. I’m not one of those
people. I have no respect for people who have
panic attacks!” Because usually panic attacks, to
me, are from people who are just like, “Oh, no,
like my cake is late, I’m going to die!” And they
freak out over shallow little things. It seems to
me that they have no perspective on life. I have
no respect for that kind of silly panic. Right?
But I had just panicked and it was involuntary.
That night I had this moment of thinking, “Wow,
what does that mean? That am I a panic attack
person now? Have I changed categories from a
not-panic-attack person to a panic-attack
person?” I fell asleep with no answers
to that. Then the next day had this
thing happened with the German couple.
That experience taught me two kinds of empathy.
We categorize people. Like the type of person who
has a panic attack. We think of a category of
person that’s, say, depressed, fat, homeless,
divorced, bankrupt. And you think, “I would never
be those things. I’m not that kind of person.”
But a lot of these things are involuntary.
It’s not like somebody chooses
to be depressed. That’s when I realized I had
been unfairly categorizing people the same way
I had unfairly categorized panic attack people
— because now I am one. Right? And addiction.
Like somebody who said they would never be an
addict and then they find themselves addicted
to something that seemed harmless at first. And
they have to admit, “Oh, my God, I’m an addict.”
But someday these categories might
be me or anybody else. If you’re
categorizing people, this might be you.
But then the thing that happened on the
second day? There’s another category that we don’t
think we could be, which is like hero, rescuer,
leader, athlete.
Millionaire! Some people
in the past few years have become millionaires,
which is something that they held in a different
category and thought “I’d never be that.”
And suddenly you have to admit, “You know,
I’m a multi-millionaire now.” It’s a category.
Tim Ferriss: Things with a positive connotation.
Derek Sivers: So I realized that even
those categories can be involuntary,
that you can suddenly be a rescuer
even if you never intended to be one,
just through the power of
imitation. You can deliberately
step into these roles by imitating others.
Tim Ferriss: So how do you now think about
labels that you apply to yourself? And I ask that
in part because as you’re speaking, I think of how
it can not only be unfair to say “I’m
this and not that” or “That person is
this and not that," but if you’re applying it
to yourself and you have very narrow categories,
so you have very finely tuned labels. I think it
makes you fragile because you are susceptible to
the the whim of chance in a way that I think is
not particularly resilient. Right? If suddenly
your circumstances change and you find yourself in
a different category, it can be really upsetting.
How do you think about what you call or don’t
call yourself? We were talking a little bit about
this at lunch before we recorded. Right? There are
people that are like, “I have read Stoicism. Now I
am a stoic!” And there’s this identity that’s
assumed, and these labels that are applied.
As much as I love Stoicism, even
though I, you know, invoked that name,
I do think you have to be careful with labels.
So how do you think about that for yourself?
Well-timed for a sip of Scotch.
Derek Sivers: Well, young man. Sit down. Sit
down.
By the way,
audience, the hardest thing about hitting record
on this is that Tim and I have these crazy,
all-over-the-place conversations in the forest
and whatnot, so it’s hard to remember that
we need to close tangents today. Usually we
open a tangent and close it two days later.
Tim Ferriss: We have to close tangents today.
Derek Sivers: Okay. So do you want me to go on
my anti -ism tangent? Are we there yet?
Tim Ferriss: Well, let’s see. Is there
some unfinished business that
we need to tidy up first?
Derek Sivers: Well, there’s a tiny idea around the
identity, which is to just admit that whatever you
are is now and whatever your preference is now.
So when my kid says “I hate tomatoes," I
say “today." And he goes, “Oh,
right, I hate tomatoes today!”
Because it’s leaving open the possibility
that you might change your mind tomorrow.
And he did! I hate olives. I hate, hate, hate
olives so badly. And he picked this up from me,
right? So he’s like, “I hate olives, too!” But he
was just imitating me. And then we went to Subway
one day. I was so proud of him. He walked
up to the counter and he said “I would like
olives.” And they said, “Do you want anything
else?” He said, “Ham, just ham and olives.”
And they loaded this sandwich full of
olives. And I looked at it horrified.
He ate it and loved it! And he goes, “I
like olives now.” I was like, “Yes.”
I love that switching between identities.
I used to call myself an entrepreneur and
other people would call me an entrepreneur. And
then I did my first book that was about that.
So I got categorized as an entrepreneur.
Tim Ferriss: Great book, by the way.
Derek Sivers: Thank you. Thank
you for writing the foreword.
Tim Ferriss: Anything You Want.
I recommend people check it out.
I’ve read it multiple times. It’s a great book.
Derek Sivers: So for years I kept calling myself
an entrepreneur until one day I realized like,
wait a second, this is expired! Like somebody
who is an athlete in high school can’t
keep calling himself an athlete forever.
Tim Ferriss: Ha! Yeah, I’ve learned that one.
Derek Sivers: You have to keep earning that
title or it expires, right? Same thing with being
a good friend. Same thing with any labels that we
call ourselves. You can’t just keep using that
forever. You have to keep it up or it expires.
So if you realize that your
previous identity is expiring,
you have the choice then of either admitting,
“I was an entrepreneur; I was a musician.”
Or if you don’t want it to expire, well, then you
need to do something about it and go actively be
a good friend, not just keep calling yourself a
good friend. Or go actively be an entrepreneur if
you want to keep calling yourself that.
Tim Ferriss: So I may be skipping ahead
because I do like mixing tangents. But that’s the
nature of conversation, especially when you have
Go Go Gadget tea and Scotch involved. So we were
talking about this the other night at dinner:
We use language, we’re creatures of language. Part
of the reason that we’ve become such a dominant
pest on the planet is our ability to
use concepts and abstraction. Right.
And you had mentioned at one point thinking
of yourself after entrepreneur as a writer.
How did you make that switch?
Derek Sivers: Looking to your heroes.
I call it my people compass. If you’re not
sure which way to go, you can ask yourself,
“Well, who do I admire? Who do I like?”
So for me, I was not sure what direction
I wanted to go. I am an entrepreneur and I’m a
programmer and I’m an author. I actually thought
about it in that order. Maybe programmer first,
entrepreneur. Then writing seemed to be something
I was doing as just like a waste product.
Tim Ferriss: Ha! A metabolite of your
other focus.
Derek Sivers:
It was like as I’m doing my thing, if I learn some
lessons, there, I just put them into writing.
But then I noticed that all of my heroes were
authors. These were the people I looked up
to the most, and that helped me realize
my values. It helped reveal my values.
So ultimately we want to be our ideal
selves, right? And that your heroes
are your idealized self, right? That’s why we
idolize certain people, is we want to be like
them. So that reveals what your values are.
So in that moment, I went, “Oh, my God,
that’s right. In my heart, I’m actually more
of an author.” Programming is fun. I love
programming. I love what it empowers. I think
we’re going to talk about that later. And I’m
not an entrepreneur anymore. So in that moment,
I was like, “That’s it. I’m really an author now,
aren’t I? Wow, that feels weird to me. I
never thought of myself as an author.”
But the reason I call it a people compass is
related to when you’re not sure what business
to start. A lot of people are looking at many
different options right now. The way I think
about it is asking yourself, “What kind of people
do I like being around?” Because these are the
people you’re going to be serving. You have to
like them. You want to love your customers and
love serving them, because ultimately, even
if it’s the money, what you really really
want is the emotional fulfillment, right?
You might get lucky by strategically choosing
an industry or a market that’s on its way up,
and you might get really lucky and become a
billionaire doing something. But what if your
customers are jerks, right? Like, would you be
happy getting rich running an all-night vaping
store? You think of the kind of customers that
would come into your all-night vaping store. Are
these the people you want to serve? And would
you be happy even if you made $1 million doing
that? I think you’d feel pretty mixed about it.
Tim Ferriss: I’m a little embarrassed to tell
you about my new startup then. Decentralized
blockchain baby seal clubbing expeditions? Yeah.
Not not sure I want to hang out with the people
who might go on that tour.
Derek Sivers: Run by AI.
Tim Ferriss: We may need a refill
on the Scotch, the way we’re going.
Derek Sivers: So, yeah, I think that if you set
up your business to serve the people that you
love being around, even if it makes less
money, you’re going to be much happier.
So that’s where I’m at right now. Right now,
I’m not an entrepreneur, but I’m starting
to get that itch. I’m starting to feel like
doing something. And if I do, it’ll just be
to be around the people that I already love.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so let’s poke at that a
little bit. Being around the people you
love. There are many ways to do that.
Why do you think you are maybe leaning
towards the entrepreneur vehicle for
doing that versus doing other things? Is
it what you know? Is there more to it?
Derek Sivers: Hmm. Because it’s asking yourself:
what would you do even if it didn’t pay?
I’ll just pick one example. And don’t hold me to
this, world, if I don’t end up doing this idea!
Do you know, that seven years ago, on your
podcast, I happened to mention that that
week we talked, I was enjoying learning the
history of hip-hop. And for six years people
keep telling me like, “So! History!”
It was just it was that week. Come on!
Tim Ferriss: “Now I like olives, so
stop lecturing me about my past self!”
Derek Sivers: So right now an idea I’m having
is 100-year hosting — legacy personal websites.
Setting up a trust so that your personal website
will last on for 100 years or 50 years after you
die. This is the kind of thing I care about so
deeply that I would do it even if it didn’t pay.
I would do it as volunteer work. And I really like
people that have personal websites. They’re my
kind of people that enjoy technology for
its own sake. People that took a little
initiative and set up their own website.
I like these people. I like people that have
personal websites that aren’t doing it for money.
They’re my kind of people and so I would be proud
to serve them. So that’s all I meant by that.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, So, so many directions
we can go here, I think.
You alluded to it, so why not hop to it?
Programming: the empowerment that can provide.
Let’s talk about escaping the cloud. All right.
Or broadly speaking, tech independence.
And to set the stage for folks, we were walking
down the street here in Wellington. Beautiful
Wellington, New Zealand. Central New Zealand.
(Ugly Wellington.) Well, yeah, the central
area is a little bit like Haight-Ashbury in
some respects, but for those people who get
the reference. But all in all, beautiful city,
lots of hiking trails, shockingly similar to
Northern California. I mean, I felt like I was
flying into SFO. You have Monterey Pine here,
you have eucalyptus, which we both borrowed
from Australia. You have nasturtiums. A lot
of the vegetation here is similar. It’s really
nostalgic and kind of eerie in a way to be
here because I feel like I’m back in Northern
California. It’s like being in a time machine.
In any case, we were walking around not in
the nature side of things, but downtown.
And I said, "You know, I’d love to ask you about
cybersecurity." And I said, "Let’s say somebody
who’s very technical and hyper paranoid, let’s
say there are 10. Let’s say your mom is a one. Not
to make assumptions about your mom, but I will.
Where do you fall on the cybersecurity spectrum?"
And that opened up a fun discussion.
We chatted. You also then wrote in
your diary about it the next morning.
Derek Sivers: Yeah, because I’m slow like that.
You’ll ask me something like that. And in the
moment, as we were walking down Courtenay Place,
I’ll give some half-ass answer. And then later
that night I’m like, “Oh, I've got a better one!”
Tim Ferriss: I’ll push back a little bit. Slow
is relative. I mean, I think that you were
very coherent and you thought about it before
you launched off into some type of monologue,
which you didn’t. It was a conversation,
but you then refined it the next morning.
So let’s let’s talk about this, because you gave
a couple of — I wouldn’t say recommendations. You
described a few things you do personally that
I found very interesting, one of which was
you don’t use the cloud. Which I think will get a
lot of people’s attention because in part I think
there are many people who feel, myself included,
that there’s something uncomfortable about it.
But I assume since I’m non-technical, there
really just is not an alternative. But there
is part of me that’s very privacy sensitive
and is fundamentally uncomfortable with having
all this stuff, all this miscellanea, all these
impulsive, ridiculous group chats and whatever
backed up somewhere else. For a lot of reasons.
Derek Sivers: Your phone book,
your calendar. All of that.
Tim Ferriss: All of that, it’s there’s
something deeply uncomfortable about
it. And yet I use the off-the-shelf
tools because everyone else does. And
I just assume there are no alternatives
that are feasible for a muggle like myself.
Derek Sivers: Poor Tim. Poor Tim. So incapable.
Tim Ferriss: All right. So, Doctor,
Doctor Sivers, please hold court.
Derek Sivers: So, audience, I
prepared. I took notes because
although I love Tim’s podcast, I love it most when
people come and give us an intense data dump. So I
prepared a couple hours and here you go.
I’m going to unapologetically read from
my notes to give you the best bang
for buck of your time listening.
So tech independence is all about the fact
that the main sales pitch of the cloud is “Now,
don’t worry your little head about that. Let us
take care of it. We’ll keep all of your data. See?
Isn’t that easier Now there we’ve got your data.”
It actually reminded me of something you said in
The 4-Hour Body about yoga studios that no,
it’s not the best thing for your health,
but it’s a more profitable pitch for them to sell
you a yoga studio instead of the free weights.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, There’s a lot of
that in fitness overall for sure. So
there’s an incentive.
Derek Sivers: This is
the tech equivalent of that.
I wish that history had gone such
a way that we all had our own little private
server at home, but instead the cloud made a
better sales pitch saying, “No, no, no, give us
all your stuff. We’ll take care of it forever.”
So my idea is if you spend a few hours to learn
how to do it yourself, you’ll just have tech
independence. What that means is self reliance. It
gives you better security, better privacy, better
freedom, better flexibility and total control.
And it’s a great use of your time to spend a few
hours learning to do this, kind of like somebody
learning to drive manual transmission. Right? You
don’t need to do it. But this is a good life skill
to have. Especially imagine if we’re in a world
that had more, you know, just 50 years ago.
Tim Ferriss: So or now in a lot of countries,
you still can’t drive automatic.
Derek Sivers: Many people have lost their Google
accounts. There’s a guy I know who’s a very savvy
tech entrepreneur in Singapore who, because he was
so tech savvy, he put all of his kid's photos in
the cloud. Since the day his kid was born, he put
everything onto Google Photos for 10 years. His
kid was 10 years old the day that he started a new
company and said, “I’m going to do the Google Apps
for business." And it asked him a quick question:
“Would you like to merge this with your existing
Gmail account?” He said, "Yes." He merged it. And
the next day his wife was like, “Honey, where are
all the photos of our kid?” He went, “They’re in
Google Photos.” She said, “No, they’re not.” And
he looked, and was like, “Oh, my God, what do you
mean they’re gone?” He emailed customer service
and they said, “Well, no, you chose to merge your
accounts and we warned you that they’re gone.” And
he said, “Well, could you please recover them?”
They said, “No, they’re gone.” This poor guy has
no photos of his kid from age 0 to 10 because he
trusted the clown. I mean, sorry, cloud.
Tim Ferriss: He can’t trust those clowns.
Derek Sivers: Sorry. Tech snark.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, you did you do that on purpose?
Derek Sivers: I did.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that was good.
Derek Sivers: So, yeah, any
time when somebody talks about
the cloud, you know, change it to an N.
Derek Sivers: The cloud. The clown. Keep
all my contacts in the clown.
So everything I’m going to describe here
takes just a few hours to set up. This isn’t a
major, major thing. It’s not that hard. Listeners
of yours are used to being suggested
to learn how to do something.
Tim Ferriss: And let me also preface this for
a quick second. This is not a tangent by saying
I do not experience you. Maybe I’m missing
something. Maybe spider holes dug in the backyard.
I do not experience you to be a hyper-paranoid
person at all. So I just want to mention that
because folks might think, “Oh, my God, this guy’s
got like 20 years' worth of oatmeal and like,
you know, gold bars and guns in the basement.” I
want to sort of set the proper reference point,
which is I don’t experience you to
be a paranoid person. Not at all.
Derek Sivers: So first, let me
just say the first thing you need is to get your
own server, which is as simple as $5 a month.
Go to a company I recommend called vultr.com.
They have something called cloud compute for
$5 a month where basically that’s
setting up a private slice that’s
just yours but on a shared computer. So it’s —
Tim Ferriss: Like a virtual private server.
Derek Sivers: Virtual private server.
Exactly. I was trying to not get technical.
Tim Ferriss: A server, for people who
don’t know, I know this is going to be
old news for a lot of folks. What is
a server? Sounds super complicated.
Derek Sivers: It’s not. It’s just a computer
that’s always online and publicly accessible.
Doesn’t even necessarily need to
be public. We’ll get to that.
For setting up your server,
there are three options.
#1 = the $5 a month vultr.com cloud compute.
#2 = search the web for cheap dedicated server.
A dedicated server is an actual piece
of hardware that is only yours not
shared with anybody else. So if you want
more privacy, just spend a little extra
money and get a dedicated server.
Which means this physical hardware,
you’re the only person that has access. They
have physical access to it, but you have the
only root password and it’s going to be an
encrypted hard drive. We’ll get to that.
Third option is go to any used marketplace and
find an old used Lenovo ThinkPad, ideally from the
T400 series. You can get these for under $200 now
and they’re great and they run any old operating
system. You would just set this up in your closet
and keep the master version of your server in your
closet. And then the other things would be mirrors
of that. But we’ll get to that in a second.
Okay. So here’s my quick how to — I’m
going to tell you a few things here that
aren’t complete instructions, but they’re
enough for you to search the web. So I’ll
tell you what to do. And you can
search the web for exactly how.
The first thing you’re going to need to do is to
use the Terminal. So the command line in the Mac,
it’s built in. You go into the Utilities
folder, it’s called Terminal. On Windows
it’s called PowerShell. And anybody
using Linux, you know what it is.
So the operating system I’m going to
recommend, the one I use is called
OpenBSD. And we touched on this on the street
the other night. The reason I use OpenBSD.
(BSD = Berkeley Software distribution. Actually, I
was born in Berkeley, California and kind of like
more people named Dennis go into dentistry because
there’s an affiliation of names. Freakonomics
pointed that out. I always wonder if my affinity
with the BSD operating systems is because I was
born in Berkeley and the Berkeley, who knows?)
But the reason I got turned on to OpenBSD is
because I used to have Linux server as a public
server and it was hacked one day and the guy
at the data center said, “Yeah, that’s been
happening a lot lately. Said you might want
to switch to BSD. It’s a lot more secure.”
So OpenBSD is designed from the ground up
by super security freaks. And part of why it’s
so secure is it’s so simple. It’s a very, very
simple operating system that doesn’t do everything
under the sun. It does what I’m describing, and it
does it really well. And it’s secure as hell.
Tim Ferriss: And it’s got, as I understand it,
few lines of code. Which means, let’s just
say you’re a writer. The more you write,
the higher the frequency of typos. And you don’t
want bugs in your code that can be exploited.
Derek Sivers: The less code, the better.
So install OpenBSD and follow the instructions
to encrypt one of the disk partitions
in there, as you’re installing it.
Then you’re going to use SSH, which
stands for Secure Shell, to log into it.
Then on your home computer, use that
terminal to generate a private SSH key.
You do ssh-keygen -t ed25519. That’s going to
generate two keys, a private key and a public
key. You upload the public key to your server.
After you do that, edit your SSH configuration
file to disable password logins. So now the only
way to log into your server is with your private
public key that you just generated. Right? Very
similar to the crypto public/private thing.
Then you go into your pf.conf settings, you
edit your firewall to only allow port 22,
which is the port that SSH uses to connect.
Once you’ve done that, voila, now your server
is super secure. Nobody can get in
except you from your computer with
the generated private key through SSH is
the only way to connect to that server.
Tim Ferriss: Explain the generated private key.
Derek Sivers: Really just a single command. You
type on the terminal “ssh-keygen -t ed25519."
It will ask you for an optional password and
it just creates the private key and the public
key. Same name, but one has the “.pub” at the
end. Then you just use whatever tool you want to
upload the pub to your remote server. You put it
into the correct place and authorized keys file
and voila. Now it will, instead of asking you
for your password, just use the private key
and the public key matching to let you in.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. So it’s like Marco Polo.
Okay. Yeah, we’re in. As opposed to entering
a password every time.
Derek Sivers: Right.
And that’s why you want to change the SSH server
configuration files to disable passwords. So
even if a billion script kiddies were trying
to hack your server to guess your password,
passwords are just disabled.
Tim Ferriss: Do you think this will
become — and I’m non-technical, folks, you’ve
probably guessed — but this type of Marco Polo,
I can’t remember the proper way the private keys
and so on, private/public keys or whatever the
term is, will become more and more prevalent as
quantum computing and so on allow the current
level of encryption to be decrypted more and
more effectively? I’m just wondering about, well,
this is going to take us off on a major tangent.
Derek Sivers: I think it’s what our phones are
already doing behind the scenes with WhatsApp,
encrypted chats, or FaceTime or even just our
phones themselves. When you type in that
code, when you first turn on your phone,
I think our phones are already behind the scenes
using public/private key. So that’s just the best
solution so far, I think.
Tim Ferriss: Side note,
if you have a four-digit password on your
phone, you can change that to eight-digit.
Simple, simple upgrade. Yeah. In settings.
Derek Sivers: So next thing you need a domain
name. My recommended place to get a
domain name is a wonderfully nerdy,
non-commercial site called BookMyName.com.
Wait till you see the site. It’s wonderful,
old school nerdy. There’s
no affiliate program there.
As a backup, I use NETIM.com. Both of
these are French companies, and there’s
a third one in Portland, Oregon that I like called
Porkbun.com . All three of these are really good,
reputable places to get a domain name. I
recommend them. I just like them. I use them.
Once you’ve got your own server, it puts
everything else into perspective. So that’s really
where I’m coming from when I say I don’t do things
in the cloud. It’s because when companies come out
and say, “We can take care of this for you," Yeah,
it’s like you’ve already got your bread and peanut
butter and jam in the kitchen and somebody says,
"We can make a sandwich for you in your own home."
You think “I don’t need your help.”
Tim Ferriss: So for those who heard,
the Scotch really just hit me like, Good
Lord, that was not very much. But you’ll
have extra personality for this episode,
folks. So for those people who listen to
what you just said and they’re like, "I think I
just heard a lot of Klingon, I’m not sure, but
I can’t parse what any of that means." It sounds
overwhelming, right? What would you say to them?
Derek Sivers: I care about this so much that I’m
going to set up a really dead simple thing that’s
basically just “Do this, copy/paste this. This
is going to work. Look at that.” So email me.
Tim Ferriss: God damn it. Email? Write a blog!
Derek Sivers: I will. I will. But yeah. Blog
post. What’s that?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. You’ve only
written five million blog posts since like 1987.
Derek Sivers: But until. Until I write up —
actually, you know what? I registered the domain
name cloudfr.ee. I just thought it was clever.
Someday I’m going to write
this up into a very simple
“You don’t need to understand this
yet. Just do this. Eventually you’ll
understand it.” Because that’s how I learn.
Derek Sivers: Because that’s how we all learned
at first, right? It’s often like, "Just do this.
You’ll understand it later. Yeah, but for now,
just do it." And I think that’s a fine way to
learn if you trust the source. Right. Trust me.
Tim Ferriss: “Where are my photos?
Oh, Derek Sivers has all my photos."
Derek Sivers: Right? Right. That’s what
I really wanted. I want your photos!
Tim Ferriss: “Let’s talk describing
how to hit a baseball.” You’d be like,
“What the fuck? That was like 15 pages of
describing. And that sounds too hard.” Actually,
no, you’ve just got to try it a few times.
Derek Sivers: Yeah. Okay. So, by the way, you
know what’s cute? My kid didn’t know what baseball
is. They played baseball last week at school,
and he said, "Dad, what’s this thing with the
squares? And he hit a home run on his first try."
Tim Ferriss: Oh, wow. It’s all
downhill from there. Tell him to stop.
Derek Sivers: Yeah, exactly. “Everybody was
cheering for me, but I didn’t know what I was
supposed to do. They told me to run.”
Okay, so now let’s talk about some
applications. Okay, so you have a server set
up. Here’s what you’re going to do with it.
First, do your contacts and calendar. I don’t
like the fact that my phone automatically
gives Google all of the contacts and
all of my calendars or Apple. So you
can set up it’s called Radicale. The website is
Radicale.org. It’s absolutely free. Open source.
It sets up what’s known as a CardDAV and a
CalDAV server on your server. So this just
this will be the new server that you
sync your contacts and calendars to.
So it’s dead simple. Blew my mind. You
install Radicale on your server. You just
basically type one command and it says, "Okay,
it’s running," and you say, "Okay." And then
you go into your phone and instead of telling
Apple to manage your calendar and contacts,
you just set it to your domain name. And suddenly
it says, "Okay, synchronized." And now every new
contact you add and every calendar entry is
synchronized with your server, not Apple’s.
Tim Ferriss: And actually, I have gone through
this process before and I can tell people it’s
quite simple because things have probably changed.
But quite a few years ago, if you wanted your
iCal on Mac and Google Cal to sync, huge pain
in the ass, right? You would have to use a third
party. And at least I ended up using CalDAV a long
time ago. That’s since changed. But yeah, so this
is not this is not very, very hard. Dead easy.
Derek Sivers: That’s why I started with this.
Yeah. It’s like the simplest thing to set up.
Tim Ferriss: And the most sensitive in a way.
Or some of the most sensitive. Yeah, right.
Derek Sivers: It feels so important to know
that my contacts aren’t being sent to
other people, and then you see it backed
up yourself. Because there are some people
that get locked out of their Gmail account
or whatever and then they’re just screwed
because all their contacts are in there,
but you have them yourself.
Okay, so next thing is file storage,
where photos, ebooks, movies, documents,
everything else. They’re just files.
So the first thing you want to do is to
export them out of the apps that are like
the walled garden apps like Kindle and Apple’s
Photos app. And save it as regular files epub,
jpg, mp3, mp4. Just open standards.
So you export it out, you save it
there. And now you’ve just got regular files.
You don’t need iCloud, you don’t need Dropbox,
you don’t need Google Drive.
You’ve got your own server.
Every computer has this dead simple little program
built into it called rsync. Macs have it built in.
Windows I think you might need to install it
or maybe it’s there with the new PowerShell.
And all it does is synchronize the difference.
So if you have 10,000 files and you’ve changed
three of them today and your remote server
has 10,000 files, but not the new three,
you type "rsync" and it’ll just send the
newest three that you’ve changed. That’s it.
Rsync is built in, but you have to manually
type "rsync" and the command and your server
name and it’ll go. So that’s what I do.
But if you’re a fan of Dropbox, there is a
free replacement for Dropbox called Syncthing.
Syncthing.net. It’s totally free open source.
Tim Ferriss: I want to give you more Scotch.
Just see what it does to your spelling.
Derek Sivers: And it does that more like automatic
style instead of manual synchronization.
Tim Ferriss: Well, let me pause. So in your
particular case, do you think automatic sync,
do you like automatic sync?
Derek Sivers: I don’t. I like
having the delay between my servers.
Tim Ferriss: Because if you fuck up —
Derek Sivers: Yes, right. If I accidentally
delete a file, even if it’s a week later,
we’ll get to — actually, you know
what? I’ll talk about this right now.
I have my servers cloned, so that’s actually
the next step I would recommend. Once you’ve
got this and it’s working for extra security, go
back and repeat that first step and set up another
server with a different company in a different
country and do it again. Do the SSH port thing.
Then you can use rsync or Syncthing, not just
to clone between your computer and your server,
but that server and the other server.
Tim Ferriss: I have a great idea.
Okay. You ready?
So this next chapter
of Doctor Sivers’ entrepreneur interacting
with customers: You like to own personal
websites. You could create a service that helps
people liberate themselves from the cloud.
For those who own personal websites.
You know, it’s just an idea because you seem to be
philosophically aligned with this.
Derek Sivers: Yeah. And I’m passionate
about it. It upsets me when people are bound to
the cloud or just going to use everything in the
company’s hand. They’re dependent on this.
It’s about being dependent! It’s about the
self-reliance! People who are dependent on
others — like imagine if everybody in their
own home was like dependent on somebody else
to make them food. They didn’t know how to make
their own food. You’d feel bad for them. Like,
“Come on, it’s not that hard. Here’s a knife,
here’s some bread, some peanut butter.
See, you could do it.” That’s how I feel
with these things.
Tim Ferriss: You
only need three glasses. It’s easy.
Derek Sivers: All the things I didn’t
think we’d talk about!
Tim Ferriss:
I would also say that it’s not just about being
dependent. It’s about being informed. So do you
have complete understanding or near-complete
understanding of how you are storing sensitive
information? When’s the last time anyone listening
to this — or even I’ll speak for myself — yours
truly — read the complete terms and service? When
something pops up and it’s 27 pages and you’re
like, “Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, click accept.”
There’s a lot of stuff buried in there. Yeah,
there’s a reason there are armies of
lawyers that work on terms of service
and that they’re updated constantly.
Derek Sivers: Which is nice to tune
into sources, people who care about
that stuff deeply — and they can act
as a nice natural filter to let you know
if somebody is being good or being bad.
That’s how I found BookMyName.com for domains.
It was some super nerd that recommended that,
they’re like, “Oh, these guys are old school
Unix. You want to go with these guys. Like,
you know, they’re not these new salesmen
trying to, you know, raise venture capital
for their domain selling. These are just old
school nerds doing it for the right reason.”
That’s what I like to hear. These are my people.
So I have three servers now set up in New Zealand,
US, and Germany, and I like the delay between
them. I have one that I update every night,
sometimes multiple times a day manually. Yeah,
I just type "rsync" right before I shut down.
My computer backs up my whatever today’s work
to my remote server and then about once a week
I back it up to the second server. Then about
once a month I back it up to the third server.
And I really like that delay because there have
been times that I’ve deleted something and like
a whole week later went, "Oh, crap."
Tim Ferriss: Let me ask, let me ask a
dumb question, maybe. Why delete
anything? Storage is so cheap.
Derek Sivers: I know. No, I mean more
like deleted lines of code, like,
"I thought I was done with that."
Tim Ferriss: There was a
revision that you want to undo.
Derek Sivers: Yeah. And sometimes I’m using Git.
But sometimes I’m not. And sometimes it’s gone.
It’s rare, but every now and then. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay, so a website is a no-brainer. The
OpenBSD operating system comes with its
own web server, so I highly recommend it.
No offense, don’t install WordPress.
We love you, Matt. I adore you, Matt, but I think
everybody should learn how to do it themselves.
It’s not that hard to do an
H1 tag, H2, P tag, UL, LI,
href, img src. You can learn it in an hour. And
voila, now you can make your own HTML website.
I get this question about once a week
by email people saying, “What do you
recommend? I want to make my own site.”
Tim Ferriss: Well, hold on. So not not
to push back, but just to stress test a little
bit. WordPress is open source. Why not use it?
Derek Sivers: You could, but, see, WordPress
is like, I think last time I counted 38 billion
lines of code. And it does way more than what
you need. So it’s kind of like if you said,
"I need some scissors," and somebody handed you to
the contents of an entire hardware store. You’re
like, “No, I really just need to cut this.”
So I think most people, what they want from a
website is, “I have some thoughts. I want to put
them in writing for the world to read.” Or “I have
a couple photos.” That’s what most people want.
I love WordPress and I used it for years,
but it does everything and I think it
intimidates people to the point of paralysis.
So that’s why I say, “Well, no, no, no, no, hold
on.” My top recommendation is don’t let people
tell you that this is complicated because if you
look at WordPress or similar services and — by
the way, I’m just saying WordPress, I mean, it
could be Ghost, it could be any of these things.
You get the impression that making a website is
hard, but it’s not. It’s just a plain text file
that you change the extension from .txt to
.html, and you add in a couple bracket tags,
and that’s it. And then you upload it
and it works and the world can see it.
So I just constantly remind people how simple
this can be. And I say that even if you just
do it this way for the first month, please,
like, make your own static HTML web page.
Tim Ferriss: I think it’s a good exercise,
even if you end up later using something else.
Derek Sivers: Exactly right.
Tim Ferriss: That’s what I was getting to.
Derek Sivers: So start by doing it that
way. And then if you need something that
another service offers, you’ll recognize
that you need it because you’ll know.
Tim Ferriss: I agree with that. I mean, I edited
the first 30 to 40 episodes in my podcast, which
is a lot of work, and I’m not a master at it, and
there are far better people who work on it now for
these later episodes. But I felt good doing it in
the beginning and I was like, all right, if I’m
going to delegate anything to the extent that it’s
feasible, I’d love to learn how to do each thing.
Otherwise, how am I going to assess anything?
Derek Sivers: Okay. I’ll name one last one
and then we’re done with this subject. The
last thing I’m going to recommend is email.
So at very least get off Gmail and use
your own domain name. It’s so important to
switch your email to your own domain name.
Tim Ferriss: You can do that with G Suite.
Derek Sivers: I know, but we’re talking about
the liberation, the independence. It’s knowing
that you aren’t dependent on these guys!
So I think it’s crucial to extract yourself
from the “We’ll take care of it for you” thing.
So the three things I’m going to recommend in the
three different options in order:
The simplest, cutest little one I’ve
found is Mailbox.org in Germany. For $1 a month
they do nothing but host your email and I think
maybe your calendars. But you know, we’ve already
talked about that. Mailbox.org, you point your
domain name at them. They do your mail. They’re
cute, they’re great. They’re all privacy focused.
If you want the luxury full premium suite
of like the best email client on earth,
you go to Fastmail.com. Fastmail.com
is amazing. It’s $5 a month.
But again, they’re taking care of it for you.
So, you know, the third option is coming. You
can host your email yourself on your own server.
It’s dead easy to receive email. It’s a little
harder to send email. You’d have to set up a few
config files, but it’s not that hard. I do it
myself. It’s a bit advanced, but it’s possible.
I assume that that would come maybe as you know,
step eight after you’ve done other things right.
Tim Ferriss: That’s like if you’re starting on the
bunny slopes, which were the first stages,
this is like, okay, now you’re getting on
some moguls. Yeah, don’t try this day one.
Yeah. Get familiar with the gear first.
So I would be curious to know how you would
reply to people who are listening and they’re
like “Mailbox.org and Germany Fastmail? I’ve
never fucking heard of these things.” Which is
not to say they’re not robust and amazing
and cute, as you put it, but they’ll say,
"I have more confidence in Google being around
in five years than I do in these companies,
which I know nothing about." Ultimately,
you can have a certain degree of liberation,
but if your infrastructure fails or these people
put up a "Closed for Business" sign and suddenly
the hardware upon which things are being stored
is game over, I guess I’m wondering how you would
address people with those types of concerns?
Derek Sivers: Everything I’ve recommended here
was recommended with that in mind. You should
expect that you will outlive most businesses.
I think that is the biggest misconception
that people have about Facebook
or Apple or Google. It’s likely you might outlive
Google and Facebook. You know, those of us who
were around in the first dot-com boom.
Derek Sivers: History repeats. Yeah, it’s
certainly well within the realm of possibility.
Derek Sivers: It was unthinkable in 1999 that
MySpace wouldn’t be around,
maybe. What was that, 2003?
Tim Ferriss: So how is how is Mailbox.org better?
Derek Sivers: Everything is done with your own
domain name. So if Mailbox.org ever ends —
actually, if they just disappeared one day,
you’d just log into your domain name router
and just route it to another service. Because
everything’s being sent to tim@tim.com or
whatever. You have your own domain name,
you can just route it to a different mail server.
Same thing with the servers I’m talking about. If
one of these services in Germany or New Jersey
suddenly went under, no big deal, you’ve got
your clone, your remote clone, your remote
server is a clone of your home thing, right?
So all of this is expecting everybody to fail.
So the conclusion is I think this is a great
use of your time. It’s liberating, It’s
empowering. And then when somebody tries
to sell you a service, you’ll know that
you can do it yourself if you want to,
and you might still choose to have them do it.
Tim Ferriss: Question for you. So if somebody is
listening and they say, There’s no fucking way I’m
going to do all that, however, I’d be interested
in dipping my toe in the water and maybe doing
the first thing just to learn some new technology,
gain some confidence. I’m not going to do the
whole kit and caboodle because it just sounds
overwhelming. But like, I want to do sort of
a science project with some experimentation.
What might you recommend to them?
Derek Sivers: I’d say the first baby
step is to get your own domain name, definitely,
and then move your email off of Gmail and just
go to some third-party provider of email.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. So you’d start with email?
Derek Sivers: I think so. It’s the simplest. It’s
the only one in there that’s not truly setting up
your own server. Although yeah, I mean, that
would obviously — that’s the next step. Just
do that first thing and have like a couple hours
of something that feels uncomfortable and new to
you. But voila, you have a server that’s running
anywhere in the world. And once you have a server,
everything else is easier. The baby step
is to just get your own domain name and
switch your email to that and try to
just move everything off of Gmail or
just let your old Gmail be your junk account.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Question for you personally,
if you had to choose between having
your email off of the cloud or
calendar and contacts, but you can only choose
one, so calendar and contacts come together,
emails another, which would you choose?
Derek Sivers: I don’t know why there’s a
sense of happiness in having my calendars
and contacts be on my own server.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I lean that
way too. And I don’t know if I
could verbalize why that’s the case.
Derek Sivers: Mail sending has become
unfortunately difficult because a lot
of things get marked as spam unless
you do a bunch of more complicated things.
Tim Ferriss: That’s right. I didn’t think about
that. I could see that being a huge problem.
Derek Sivers: So the way I actually have my mail
server set up right now is all incoming
email comes directly into my server,
but for sending I actually use a service called
Mailgun that just handles the sending so they
take care of all the deliverability.
Tim Ferriss: So it’s not an ISP,
but it’s helping. Or maybe it is an ESP
like an email service provider. Oh, it is,
yeah. I guess for outgoing only.
Yeah. I think — I wonder. I think
SendGrid does handle some of this as well.
Derek Sivers: Yeah, they’re one of the same.
Derek Sivers: So you really just using their
servers just to send the outgoing mail,
but receiving it privately.
Derek Sivers: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: SendGrid. Those guys have done
such a good job, at least last I checked and
I met them when they were just starting. I met
them at Techstars a million years ago and this
is an example of where being non-technical hurt
me because I just didn’t know what I was looking
at. The guys were super great, clearly very
smart, but I was like, "I don’t understand."
God, do I love the Shopify guys. They’re
so great. Tobi, Harley, the whole gang,
just great humans. It makes me so happy
when the good the good guys and gals do
well. It just makes me so happy.
So, cute story. Which I had
never heard, which was shocking.
Derek Sivers: Sometimes people ask
if I can introduce them to you and
I say no. I respect your time.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I appreciate that.
Derek Sivers: So, by the way, I love
your your email address.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Which basically says, fuck off.
Derek Sivers: Yeah, basically. Yeah. It’s
essentially fuckoff@timferriss.com
Tim Ferriss: It’s not that aggressive, but it
makes it clear, like, think twice before sharing.
Derek Sivers: So I love the Ruby programming
language. And before there was Ruby on Rails,
I learned Ruby in a cabin in Sweden where I was
offline for two weeks. So I brought a programming
book with me. I was like, “Well, I’m going to be
offline for two weeks. I might as well learn
something new.” So there was this really unknown
little programming language called Ruby. I was
like, “That sounds fun.” So I grabbed this Ruby
book, installed Ruby on my laptop and went off to
this cabin in Sweden in the winter. For two weeks
I was offline and I learned Ruby for two weeks.
I came back going, “That was so much fun. I
wish I could use this to make websites.” And
there was news that there was this guy named
David in Denmark who was doing something with
websites and Ruby. So I emailed him saying,
“Hey, somebody said You’re making like a web
framework in Ruby?” And he emailed back saying,
“Not ready yet.” That’s all he said.
Tim Ferriss: And for those who don’t know,
that’s DHH, David Heinemeier Hansson.
Derek Sivers: And so then Rails came out
about eight months later and at first look, I
was just like, “Huh, this is a little confusing.
I don’t really get it.”
And so I posted to the Ruby mailing list like,
“Can anybody tell me how this works? And I’d be
happy to pay somebody for an hour of their time
to show me how this works.” So some guy named
Tobi said, “I’ll show you Rails for $100. I’ll
spend an hour with you.” So I paid Tobi $100 to
show me Rails for an hour. And he showed me over
the phone. We never met face to face. It was
all just over the phone. I was living in L.A.
And Tobi was great. He showed me how Rails works
and, like, got me really into it. I was like, “All
right, I’m in.” And so my old company, CD Baby,
we started converting everything over to Rails.
So a couple of years later, I get this email
from Tobi saying, “Hey, not sure you remember
me. The guy that taught you Rails. Could you
introduce me to Tim Ferriss? Because I’ve got
this little e-commerce thing I’m doing.”
Derek Sivers: I was like, e-commerce
thing? Pfft! “No. Sorry, dude. I don’t do
that.” And so I didn’t introduce you guys.
So I was thrilled later to find out that
Tobi’s little e-commerce thing was Shopify.
And then I was thrilled to find out like another
year or two later that you were involved.
Tim Ferriss: We met at RailsConf, of all
places. I was a speaker at RailsConf,
which I felt I was supremely underqualified.
I met him in the green room at RailsConf.
Derek Sivers: Yeah? That’s how
you met? I was going to ask you.
Tim Ferriss: That’s how we met.
Derek Sivers: Oh, wow. So, yeah, Tobi
and I’ve emailed since then about, like, joking
about. “Yeah, sorry I didn’t introduce you guys.”
Tim Ferriss: It all worked out. Tobi’s
a spectacular human. Big, big fan.
Derek Sivers: It’s kind of funny that somebody
listening to this thinks that we might be talking
about tech and programming the whole time, but
no, that’s it. We’re done. We’re not going to talk
about UNIX command line terminal stuff anymore.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, well, we’ll zig and zag,
so let’s zig a little bit. You know, there’s
so many options here for where to go next.
I think one I’d actually like to
talk about is the unoptimized life.
If you’d be open to going there next. What
do you think? Yeah. All right, let’s do it.
Derek Sivers: London.
Tim Ferriss: London.
Derek Sivers: 2019.
Tim Ferriss: This is going to be good.
Derek Sivers: On the train from Oxford to
London, with my boy. And it was one of those
days that looked like it might rain, it might
not. So we made a plan on the train. I said,
“Okay, if it’s raining, we’re going to go
to the museum. And if it’s not raining,
we’re going to the zoo.” And he said "Okay."
So we got to Marylebone Station in central
London. We walked out and he said, “You know, Dad,
I don’t want to go to the zoo or the museum.”
I said, “What do you want to do?”
He said, “Let’s just walk around.”
I said, “Sure, yeah, okay.”
We just walked around. At every
intersection he said, “Let’s go this way.” I said,
"Okay." And so he just led the way through London
that day. We walked around for eight hours.
So at one point he was jumping around park
benches and met these kids from Croatia, where
they got into a little tickling match. At
another time in a little alleyway, he saw this
huge cardboard box that was like almost as big
as he is. And he got into this cardboard box and
wore it like a turtle shell. So he walked around
London in a cardboard box for like an hour
and everybody would do double takes looking
at him. And he felt so cool in the cardboard box.
And then at some point, we found ourselves right
in front of the West End musical, Wicked. And the
show was about to begin in 10 minutes. And I said,
“Do you have any tickets? What are the best
tickets you have?” They had eighth row center
tickets. They had two left. So we’re like,
"Yeah, let’s do it. Let’s go see Wicked."
So he left his cardboard box
there. We went in and saw Wicked.
At one point he whispered to me, he said,
“Dad, I like the girl next to me.” And
later I look over and he’s holding her
hand. He held her hand. They held hands.
And so the show was over. We go home
and I tuck him into bed that night.
I said, “Did you have a good day?”
He said, “I had a great day.”
I said, “All right, so what was
your favorite thing today?”
And he thinks for a bit. And then
he said, “The cardboard box."
And I just marveled at that.
I was just thinking later, like, if I would have
planned and said, “No, we’re going to the museum.
Come on. It’s an important museum for you to
know,” then he wouldn’t have had this unoptimized
experience and stumbled into the cardboard box.
And so, of course, you know, I think about
life and I think about that day as a metaphor
for how we tend to make plans.
Because plans seem to be the tool
we use to make the most of our time. But that
doesn’t always make sense, does it? Because,
like, as you go through life, you keep getting new
information moment to moment that helps you make
the best decision for that moment, not what you
thought would be the best decision earlier when
you made plans, which was a prediction.
So I think about like, for example, this
stupid house I’m in right now. So this is my
stupid house, everybody. I don’t like this house.
But here I am.
Tim Ferriss: Guess based
on your assortment of matching wear —
Derek Sivers: Right. How much energy
I’ve clearly put into this house and making
it perfect with all of its decor.
Tim Ferriss: There’s nothing on the
walls and no furniture.
Derek Sivers: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So except for
some mice. Legitimately.
Derek Sivers: Yeah. I have three pet
mice. We were going to bring them out,
but it would be distracting.
So I thought about getting rid
of this house and getting a house that was more
suited for me. And I actually put an offer on a
place and it was a really nice place. It was at
the end of Clyde Quay Wharf, which is out there
like in the water. And oh, man, it was nice.
And so my offer was accepted and it was the
night before I was going to put down the
deposit and it was going to be mine.
I fell asleep that night thinking,
“I’m going to be so happy tomorrow.”
And then I thought, “Wait, I’m already happy.”
I’m like, “Am I going to be more happy tomorrow?
No, I’m already happy.” I was like, “Well,
then why am I doing this? Why am I spending
a bunch of money if I’m already happy?”
So I yanked it. I didn’t buy it. And
here I am in this stupid house because it
has no obstacles. It’s warm, it’s quiet.
It’s not suited to me perfectly. But
that’s okay. It doesn’t get in my way.
Then from there, I think, how many other things
in our life are we okay to just not optimize?
Right? It depends where you draw the line, right?
Your romantic relationship, your job, your family.
But nobody has the perfect family of their wishes.
Our location, where you live, our diet. Like you
have to kind of decide what’s worth optimizing
— that we don’t need to optimize everything.
It’s okay to have some things be good enough.
And so I’m so glad you brought up The Paradox
of Choice by Barry Schwartz. I really internalized
that book.The ending of that, where he says like,
"Okay, I’ve been describing the problem, so what’s
a recommendation?" And he says, "Satisficing.
There’s maximizing and there’s satisficing."
Tim Ferriss: I had no idea you were
going to bring this up. This is great.
Derek Sivers: Maximizers have been found
to feel worse about the decisions they make. They
look into every possible option. They try to make
the best possible choice, but studies show that
they feel worse about the choice they make.
Whereas satisficers may not make the absolute
best possible choice, but they feel much
better about the choices they make.
So, yeah, I think a lot of who I am
is because of satisficing. And if I seem like I
make weird decisions in life, for example like
not even continuing to pursue making money, it’s
because I’m satisficing. I really took that lesson
to heart and have shaped my life around it.
Tim Ferriss: So just for definition terms, right?
Because people might think optimizing is trying to
eke out the every last iota of improvement, right?
But I think what we’re really talking about —
Derek Sivers: Sorry to interrupt. If you were
to hear Paul McCartney go,
“Hey, Jude," you’re like,
“Whoa!” just to hear him sing two notes.
Yeah. To hear you go, “Optimizing."
That’s like — whoa. That’s classic.
Tim Ferriss: If that is my legacy,
so be it. Optimizing. Optimizing.
I think what we’re talking about is
where to focus your finite energy on improving
versus leaving things as they are. Because
I think optimizing when I think of optimizing,
optimizing is leading to optimal. What does that
even mean? Maybe it’s open ended, so it just
continues forever, but it’s a helpful word.
I’m just curious how you currently think
about where to focus your energy on improving.
Internal or externally versus leaving things be.
And this is a conversation that’s near and dear to
me, one of my most effective friends has said, I’m
paraphrasing, but he’s like, “Yeah, I optimized
for like one or two things and everything else
is good enough. Like, I just have to get it to
good enough.” Nice. That’s it. And he’s incredibly
effective in life and he’s also a very happy guy
in general. Hard to know how much of that is out
of the box versus due to the decisions and the way
he views the world, but it seems to contribute.
So how do you think about then? Where you might
maximize versus where you satisfice? Or
is it because I know it’s not good enough
across the board? I find that hard to believe.
Derek Sivers: Um. Hmm.
What do I maximize? I’m not sure.
If it’s really fun. If you think
it’s just actually really fun.
Say they get into breadmaking and they’re just
like, “I want to set like the best breadmaking."
They’re just having fun with it. Then great. They
can maximize. People who get really into high
fidelity audio and they nerd out and they know
it’s stupid. But they don’t care. They want this
thing with the gold-plated cable connector.
I think if you have fun optimizing,
then it’s worth it. If maximizing
that is, if the process is fun to you,
I think that should be the parameter.
But I think that saying
“good enough” is a superpower.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I think I really do. I really
agree with that. You know.
Derek Sivers: What's such a good lesson to learn
is that nobody cares what you’re not good at.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. I say more like publicly.
Derek Sivers: You’re going to be just known
for a few things that you’re good at.
All those things that you’re not
good at, nobody cares that you’re
not good at them. So just let it go.
Tim Ferriss: Now for the broader public,
I think that’s really useful. But you may have,
say, a significant other who cares about some of
the things that you’re not particularly good at.
Derek Sivers: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: There is that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, not that I’m recently single
and thinking about this all the time or anything.
Derek Sivers: We have spent many hours talking
about sex while walking in
the forests of New Zealand.
Derek Sivers: Sex and relationships. And well.
Tim Ferriss: Even before this podcast,
Derek setting up all these cameras
and all this stuff and then he’s like,
"I just need to take a quick shower." And I was
like, "Wait a second. What? Are we about to have
sex here? Derek, what’s happening?"
Derek Sivers: I haven’t had a shower
since yesterday. I was feeling
greasy. It was distracting.
Tim Ferriss: The unoptimized life. What effect
has that had on you paying more attention to
that? I’m leaving good enough alone because this
is something I would like to do more of. And
I’ve tried to focus with some success on making
fast especially reversible or trivial decisions,
right? If it can be undone easily.
And this is also with money,
right? Attention and money. It’s like if I’m
going to default to speed with a lot of things,
if it’s not that important or if it’s pretty easy
to reverse. And I think that’s been helpful.
Derek Sivers: I think how important it is to be
done with something so that you can move on. Like,
I don’t want open loops. Unresolved decisions.
Sitting unresolved. Sitting undecided for a
long time. I feel the weight of those unfinished
projects because I’m trying to make it perfect. I
feel the weight of those. And so I think I’ve
learned the importance of just getting things
done and finishing. And to do that, you usually
have to say good enough, you know, at some point.
I love the fact that we say we, somebody releases
an album, you release a book because there’s a
wonderful double-meaning in that word, right?
Tim Ferriss: Right, I’ve never even thought
about that. Released. Yeah, I like that.
Derek Sivers: So I think about that with
anything I post on my site, any of my books, it’s
like, all right, it’s released, it’s good enough.
Tim Ferriss: All right. I’m going to combine
this maybe another Sivers-ism. It’s not really
a Sivers-ism, but in terms of how professor Sivers
operates in the world. “Useful Not True.” We’ve
been talking a bit about this. I wanted to save
a lot of it for this conversation with the mics.
Where should we start with this?
Derek Sivers: All right. So, again,
I’m addressing the audience for a second.
So, you know, I figure I’m coming on
the podcast. This isn’t just one of our random
conversations. This is for the audience. There’s
a reason we’re hitting record. It’s for them.
We can talk freely without hitting record.
So I had to think, what’s the most useful
thing I could share with your audience that
I’ve learned? Like in the last seven years since
we last spoke? The thing that’s made the biggest
difference in my life — a superpower, a big, huge
change — to me, it’s been, in short, skepticism.
So if you wonder why I’m so happy, why I’m
thriving, why I seem to be doing well, to me,
a lot of my happiness comes from this worldview
that is radical doubt. It’s skepticism.
And so I’m going to give this the shorthand
of calling it “Useful Not True," but
the visual for it is that moment at the
end of The Matrix movie when Neo realizes
those aren’t bullets, this is just code. You
remember all the bullets come his way? Like,
"None of these rules apply to
me." That’s deep skepticism.
It’s empowering, It’s liberating.
And so what I’m going to do for a few
minutes, including little stories, is to play
Morpheus to help emancipate the listeners.
So, yes, I call this "Useful Not True."
Tim Ferriss: Preach, preach! Yeah, there we go.
Derek Sivers: So I’m going to tell you
the four bits first. And we’ll use that
make sure that we come back to this.
1. Almost nothing is objectively true.
2. Beliefs are placebos. You’ve got
to believe whatever works for you.
3. Rules and norms are arbitrary
games that can be changed. And I’m
preaching to the converted that one.
4. Refuse ideology. You need to
accept ideas individually.
Okay. There’s the structure.
So number one, almost
nothing is objectively true.
Here’s what’s true. My hand is on the table.
What’s not true is “It’s good
to do everything in moderation."
Here’s what’s not true: “Family is everything."
Here’s what’s not true: “My mother abandoned me."
Here’s what’s not true: “AI is the future."
So all of these things, people say them as if
they’re true. Or even when people make an excuse,
like, you know, “I would be more successful
if it weren’t for my family or my location
or whatever." People say these things
as if they’re indisputably true fact.
But to me, the only thing that’s true are
the things that both a cat and an alien, or
let’s say a cat and an octopus, would agree on.
Tim Ferriss: I come up with so many children’s
books ideas in this conversation.
The Cat and the Alien and the Octopus.
Derek Sivers: Because it makes you
realize that everything else is just
mental interpretation, right? Like, there we go.
This is on the table. This is true. Yeah. But
everything else, including — what’s this one?
Am I flipping you off right now? Like,
am I angry at you right now? No. Just because.
Tim Ferriss: He’s giving me the middle finger.
Derek Sivers: I’m holding up my middle
finger with the back of my palm towards Tim.
Even if people say things like, "I hate
you," does it mean that they hate you? No,
they said three words. That’s all that actually
happened. Their mouth said these words. Everything
else is an interpretation or a projection.
We have to consider why people are saying
these things. If you start to think why they said
something, it helps to dispel it. You can say,
“Oh, you know what, They’re they’re probably
just believing whatever supports the emotions
that they want to feel right now."
So if somebody has a belief
that family is everything, maybe it’s because
that was something they told their kids because
they want their kids to take care of them
when they’re older. So they want their kids
to believe that family’s everything, but they
have a self-serving reason to believe that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, possibly subconscious.
Derek Sivers: Right, right, right. I’m so
glad you said this. Have you heard
about the split brain stories?
Tim Ferriss: Why did you get up to have
a glass of water? That type of stuff.
Derek Sivers: Yeah. So this is
so important to understand that.
During brain surgery, the patient needs to stay
awake. And so there was a woman — I don’t know the
details of this. It was on the EconTalk podcast —
that during brain surgery they were poking around
in there and suddenly the woman started laughing
— the patient started laughing, and they asked,
“Why are you laughing?” And she said, “Oh,
well, it’s just it’s really funny the way
that that curtain is hanging.” And she really
thought that the reason she was laughing is
because that’s the way the curtain was hanging.
But it was actually because they were poking.
Tim Ferriss: Stimulating part
of the rudder there. Yeah.
Derek Sivers: Split brain patients, there are
some people whose left and right hemispheres
of their brain are not connected.
They’ve done tests on these people to
say into their right ear, “Please get up and
open the window” and they’ll get up and open
the window and then they’ll ask their left ear
or maybe it’s their eye, “Why did you open the
window?” And they’ll say, “Oh, it was just
a it was a little cold in here. I hope you
don’t mind.” And they really sincerely to the core
thought that’s the reason they opened the window.
And there are a couple more examples of this,
you know, a message shown to one eye and they
did something. Then they asked the other eye,
“Why did you do that?” And every time the people
make up a reason, they don’t know they’re
making it up. They give a reason why they
did that and they feel completely confident
that that is the reason why they did it.
So to me, this is the most beautiful
example. Like we actually don’t know.
So talk about deep skepticism, radical doubt. You
shouldn’t even believe anything you tell yourself,
even in your private diary when you’re saying,
“I can’t. I’m not happy in this location or I
can’t do this because of that, or I’m mad at
so-and-so.” You need to ask yourself like,
okay, that might not be true just because
I’m saying it, it might not be true.
Number two, beliefs are placebos. Two people
in the same boat, one can say, "This sucks,"
and another one can say, "This is great," but
neither one is true. No beliefs are true.
In fact, you know the little story of Richard
Branson before there was Virgin Airlines. You’ve
heard the tale that he was at an airport in
the a flight to somewhere was canceled —
Derek Sivers: Was delayed. And yeah.
Derek Sivers: And everybody was grumbling,
"Oh, this sucks." And so he kind of went to
the 20 people that were angry and said, "Hey,
if I charter a plane, will you guys split the
cost?” And they said, "Yeah." So everybody else
was angry. He looked at the same situation and
said, "This is great." And he, you know, that
was kind of the launch of Virgin Airlines. No,
not launch. You know what I mean? A predecessor.
Derek Sivers: The genesis story.
Derek Sivers: Genesis, nice word.
So no beliefs are true. When we say “I
believe,” it’s an indicator that what
we’re about to say next is not true.
Tim Ferriss: Or not evidence-based.
Derek Sivers: Yeah. Not evidence based. Yeah.
Because we don’t say “I believe in potatoes."
Tim Ferriss: Speak for yourself.
Derek Sivers: We don’t have to because
there’s a potato. Yeah. We don’t need to say
“I believe” because there it is, it exists.
So I think that whenever we say "I
believe…" such or such, it indicates
that whatever we say next is not true.
Tim Ferriss: It’s kind of like when science
is at the end of a field name. Generally, it’s
not science, not always, but very often that’s
not the case. I can think of a few exceptions.
Neuroscience, computer science. But very often
when science gets appended to something,
it’s like, "Oh, thou doth protest too much."
Derek Sivers: I like that. Yeah.
Since no beliefs are true,
I think this is liberating to realize that you
can just choose whatever belief works for you
now that helps you be who you want to be.
This is about personal empowerment. It’s
hacking yourself. If a certain belief will
help you be who you want to be right now. You
don’t need to keep believing it tomorrow.
You could believe it for three minutes or
three days or you know the rest of your life.
You’re going to find what you look for. So if
you choose to believe something, you’ll find
evidence to support your belief of anything.
So number three is that rules
and norms are arbitrary games.
This is the one where I can’t help but think
of your introduction to the world in four hour
workweek, giving so many wonderful examples of
how you don’t have to accept the world’s norms.
But it’s funny how many times the rules of the
world are stated as if they’re absolutely true.
Like “all applicants must submit their application
through the usual channels and wait to hear from
us” or “to be an expert in your field, you should
have an advanced degree from a university."
Someone made up these rules and most
people follow those rules. But they’re
not true. They’re just not absolutely true.
Realizing they’re not true gives you an incredible
advantage because you realize you can make up
the rules. So this is that Matrix moment where
the bullets are flying out and he goes, “Wait a
minute, this is just code. Somebody made this up,
but I don’t need to run this program."
But if you do that, people are going to be upset
at you. So somebody’s going to get mad at you.
And you have to know that even when they say like,
“You’re a bad person for doing this." You
have to know that that’s not true either.
And I have a cute story about that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, this this, I think,
begs a number of questions. Living
in a broader society about morally
acceptable or reprehensible behavior.
Derek Sivers: But that’s when I talk about
being who you want to be. We can’t really
address people who want to be psychopaths
or who want to be damaging because then any
time you taught anybody how to do anything,
how to fly a plane, "Hey, don’t fly it into the
World Trade Center, okay?" How to drive a car?
"Don’t drive it into a crowd of people, okay?"
You have to just understand that we’re talking
about a tool, not your psychosis that
might lead you to be a bad person. Right?
Tim Ferriss: Table that for a minute.
Derek Sivers: So I have a funny little
story that felt almost too risque to tell.
Tim Ferriss: I love too risque. We don’t record
these in front of a crowd. Always edit.
Derek Sivers: Oslo, Norway.
My band was on tour and we were there for three
nights and for the first two nights there was
this girl in the audience that was kind of making
eyes at me on the stage. And so the second night
I went to go talk to her and we hit it off and
we hung out all night long and it was wonderful.
And then — but — we didn’t have sex. (That was
funny. I was like, can I say this on the air?)
Tim Ferriss: “We did not
consummate our attraction.”
Derek Sivers: All right.
I’m just going to say it.
So but we kind of regretted it. Then it was the
third day and it was the day that I was leaving.
And there’s this big kind of central park in the
middle of central Oslo, and we’re in the park.
And, you know, housekeeping came at 10 a.m.,
like time to check out, time to go. I’m like,
and she was asking them in Norwegian
like, "Please, one more hour," and
they said, "No, get out." She’s like, "Oh."
So we go out to this park and she’s like, “Oh,
God, I wish I could be with you. I wish.” She’s
like, “God, I just so want to be with you." And
I was like, “Damn, me too. I wish we could.” And
then I looked around and this park is surrounded
by Sheraton, Hilton, Marriott. And it was 11:00
a.m. and my ferry was leaving at 4:00 p.m.
Oh, and there’s one detail. She was just in
the process of breaking up with her fiancé.
Tim Ferriss: A small detail.
Derek Sivers: So this matters because,
I said, "Hey, what do you think about
getting a hotel for a few hours?"
She was like, “Well, we could.”
I was like, “Yeah, it feels kind
of naughty, doesn’t it? Let’s do it.”
“Yeah, okay. You don’t mind?” She’s like, “But
I can’t be seen with you.” She said, “Just on the
chance that a friend of mine walks by. I can’t be
seen going into a hotel with some strange man.”
I said, “Okay, so here’s what we’ll do. I’ll go
into the hotel, I’ll get a room,
and then I’ll text you the room
number and you come up a few minutes later.”
She said, "Okay, good." So I went into the hotel
and whatever hotel it was — I’ll just say Sheraton
— it was like, “Welcome to the Sheraton Hotel.”
And I said, “Hi, I’m here for
one night. I’d like a room.”
“Great, no problem. Okay. Tomorrow, breakfast will
be served over here and such and such. And here’s
your room.” Okay. He gives me my keys. So I go
up to the room and I text her the room number,
and she comes up five minutes later.
So then we have fun for a few hours
and it’s great. But now it’s 2:30 and
it’s time for me to go get my ferry. So
this time we reverse it. I go down alone first.
I go to the guy at the front desk and I say, “Hey,
I’ve decided to catch the 4:00 ferry.”
And he said, “Oh, is everything okay?
Was there any problem?”
I said, “No, no problem at
all. Everything’s great. Just decided to catch an
earlier ferry.” So, paying in full. Here it is.
So he’s charging my card. It’s already done. He’s
doing the thing. But then he sees her walk by
and he goes, “Wait a minute, I don’t like this
one bit.” So he remembers that he saw her come
in five minutes after me. Now she’s leaving five
minutes after me and he goes, (SHOUTING) “This is
not some two-bit establishment. This is this is
a very reputable hotel. I do not like this. No,
you must not do I don’t like this one
bit.” And he was getting really angry.
And I was so happy because — not for the obvious
reason. It was so liberating, realizing that I’ve
done nothing wrong. Nobody was hurt. This is fully
consensual. They were paid for their room and
even though he’s angry, he can’t get me
in trouble. I haven’t broken the law.
I think that we, so often as kids, we spend so
much of our life — the first half of our life —
deferring to authority and thinking that authority
has power over us. And at a certain point,
you realize that you’re free. You’re liberated
from that as long as you don’t break the law.
Even if people tell you you’re a bad person,
that it’s not true. They’re just saying that
because of their rules or whatever.
So this to me was a major turning
point in my life, realizing that I was
liberated from authority and from judgment.
Tim Ferriss: So a couple of things. So the
first is. I read a piece recently. I think the
author’s name is Ava. Ava, I don’t know her full
name, Book Bear on Substack. And the headline,
the title of the piece is Something like “On Not
Disappointing Myself.” And it’s a discussion of
disappointing others. How disappointing others,
but not disappointing yourself, is important. I
mean, that’s the kind of upshot of it. Very well
written. Introduced to me by a friend named Mike.
Thank you, Mike. So I recommend people take
a look at that because I think it relates
since you made mention of the fiancée.
Though I want to stand in for some of the
audience who will say, “Well, wait a second, you
said you didn’t do anything wrong, but we live
in a society. We do follow rules, otherwise
we are with the animals. So what is good,
what is bad is based on societal norms?” I’m
sure there are people listening who are like,
“Well, wait a second, you had fun for a couple
of hours with someone who is still engaged.”
How would you respond to people
who find that morally repugnant?
Derek Sivers: They had broken up but
were still living together because
she just hadn’t moved out yet.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. All right.
Derek Sivers: I wouldn’t
sleep with somebody’s wife.
But no, I know what you mean. But in
those moments, you have to ask yourself,
“Do I agree with this rule?”
Because, especially if you travel
the world, what’s polite in Japan can be rude
in New Zealand and vice versa. These different
ideas of what is the right and wrong thing to
do are completely arbitrary and they change
with geography. And so you get to kind of pick or
choose and you can choose to fit into the local
norms, or sometimes you choose not to because
you disagree with them. And that same goes the
same with individuals and people that
you are liberated from others norms.
You can choose your own.
Tim Ferriss: So there’s a lot of this that
I agree with. I also wonder how we avoid maybe we
don’t, but sinking into a moral relativism where
everything is okay on some level because nothing
is objectively good or bad. Therefore, genital
mutilation of 12-year-old girls or whatever it
is, is totally fine in that culture because the
culture is different. Therefore, I’m not going to
object to anything like that. Because I am not the
arbiter of universal truth. Therefore, everything
is okay in different cultures, different places,
different households, because everything
is relative. How do you think about that?
Derek Sivers:
I defer to Sam Harris.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Derek Sivers: Did he ever
talk about The Moral Landscape on your show?
Tim Ferriss: I don’t think we’ve discussed
it explicitly. So why don’t why don’t you, if
you wouldn’t mind elaborating?
Derek Sivers: Probably the best elaboration is
to tell people to go search for Sam Harris. Moral
Landscape. The best TED talk I’ve ever seen. Ever.
Sam Harris. The Moral Landscape so beautifully
summarizes this idea of judging something morally,
objectively based on individual well-being.
Tim Ferriss: Utilitarianism. Like greatest good
for the greatest number of people type stuff?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Derek Sivers: He says it better than I can.
Yeah, go find that talk.
Tim Ferriss: I’m curious. There’s a tension
sometimes in my mind between living a
self-authored unorthodox life that does
not conform to convention for the sake of
conforming to convention while also trying to
have some type of a consistent moral compass.
And that is why sometimes I’m actually
very envious of people who are deeply
religious. It’s like, “Here are the rules!”
I mean, you want to talk about Paradox of Choice,
like how much decision fatigue does that
remove? I’m actually very envious of that
sometimes. So how do you think about
— and I’m not saying you should think
about it. I’m just curious — let’s
just say outside of breaking the law,
you can do anything. Right. There is a just like
having 1,500 different types of toothpaste at the
supermarket and having to choose one. There is
a possible decision fatigue there. Do you use,
for yourself, you can define it yourself
— like good or bad, or some type of
moral framework for helping to narrow the
choices that you make available to yourself.
How do you think about that? In secular societies,
I think about, I wonder about this a lot..
Derek Sivers: I recently read a book I can
recommend for anybody called What Everyone [Needs
to] Know About Islam. And it was really good. And
I finally understand about the different Sharia
law, Sharia laws. It’s really congruent, more
than anything. If I had to pick one word to give,
it’s amazing how congruent it is and what peace
that can bring in a society where even the
the government laws are aligned with the
religious laws which are aligned. Everybody
here agrees in this code. It’s not a grey area.
But you asked me the other day about — I said
that I’m very influenced by the greater good —
doing things that even if it doesn’t serve me
personally or privately — if it seems
like it’s the right thing to do,
I’ll do what seems to be the right thing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah. This came up
very organically in our conversation.
Derek Sivers: I don’t remember how. Do you?
Tim Ferriss: Yes, I do remember, because
I think I was talking about how I do not
identify as a philanthropist, even though I do a
lot of nonprofit work, because I actually have a
pretty Hobbesian view of human nature in general
and think we’ve certainly, on a planetary level,
caused more problems than we’ve solved.
And therefore, I don’t phil — like philosophy,
right? Like hydrophilic like philic is to
love — phil is the etymology of that. And
then the philanthropy is like the Anthropocene
or anthropology. It’s human. So like to love
humans basically is philanthropy. And I don’t I
don’t feel like I align with that. I’m actually
a like misanthrope a lot of the time.
So I said, no, I don’t think about that
and therefore I make decisions about A, B,
or C in the following way. When it relates to
some of the nonprofit work and
scientific research that gets funded
through the Saisei Foundation, my foundation.
And that, I think, is what prompted you to say,
“I’m not sure if I think of myself as an
altruist. But I seem to make decisions for
the greater good.” Which I’ve observed in you.
I think that is the rewinding the tape. I think
that is the stream of conversation that
led to that coming up. But I was asking
about how you consider constraining your
choices with maybe a lens of morality.
And so you were going to say — .
Derek Sivers: Well, for me personally,
we have this gut feeling of what feels right and
feels wrong. Sometimes you actually let your head
rule that decision, to say, you know what, I know
that personally I might want such and such, but I
know that ultimately that it’s not that important.
Or maybe the fact that I’m happy anyway.
Affects a lot of my decisions that it’s like I
don’t need to have some million dollar thing to
make me happy. I’m already happy. Like I’ve hit
the maximum. There is no such thing as happier.
I’m already there. So therefore this million
dollars should just go to people who can use
it because that’s for the greater good.
Like that’s how my brain honestly works.
But you know. This idea of -isms. Ideologies
and subscribing. Yeah. You tapped into
decision fatigue. It really helps decision
fatigue to say, “I’m all in on this,” but I
think that people do it to a fault where they read
a self-help book and go, “Oh, yeah, this is it.
This is the answer. I’m following this now.”
Stoicism, you know, everybody’s suddenly
declaring themselves to be a stoic.
Tim Ferriss: Or religion or CrossFit or veganism.
Crypto, for that matter.
Derek Sivers: Something related
to you happened to me on a plane years ago
that I think is a good example of this. Long,
long ago — I think it was 2008 or 9 — I was on
a plane from Amsterdam to the US and I saw a guy
reading The 4-Hour Workweek and I said, “Hey,
great book.” And he goes, “It’s trash, man.”
And I said, “Really?”
And he goes, “This guy
is full of himself. This book is trash.”
And I think about that all the time because
he found one thing he disliked
about you and therefore declared
all 400 pages of this book to be trash.
And I think that’s the problem with -isms,
is that if you’re trying to buy
into a system, it’s all or nothing.
If the leader of a movement says something
you don’t like on on social media, well,
now the bubble is popped. It’s a fly in the dish.
It’s a hair in the meal. It’s a poo in the pool.
The whole thing is ruined. Drain the pool.
Tim Ferriss: That’s page four to
seven. And you’re Dr. Seuss, right?
Derek Sivers: Oh, yeah. We’re back to that.
Tim Ferriss: The cat, the alien and the octopus.
Derek Sivers: But it’s the mindset that wants
everything to be a religion. I think
that’s deeply built into people.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. The reductionism.
I mean, it simplifies reality.
Derek Sivers: Simplifies
reality. Yeah. I like that.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, you do assume
cognitive burden to take the harder path.
Derek Sivers: So on that note, like back to my
whole “Useful Not True." My radical doubt. Super
skepticism. Yes. I think we should be skeptical
of every -ism. I think we should avoid -isms,
avoid ideology, and take ideas piecemeal.
Which means ideally you should be open to
taking good ideas from people you don’t like, and
the people you do like admitting that some of the
things they say, you’re not going to adopt that.
And when somebody does that, to me, that shows
a a stronger thinker, a clearer thinker, somebody
who’s looking at ideas individually instead of
just saying, “I’m all in on this, I am a such
and such -ist. Yeah I subscribe to this -ism.”
That to me seems to be a jumping
to a conclusion. It’s a punt.
It’s like just deferring to the -ism.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah. This, this is
very present for me in the US. And we don’t need
to go into politics. But with respect to politics,
because I am asked frequently, like, “Are
you a Democrat or a Republican? Oh, wait,
I think you’re a Libertarian.” I’m like, “I
refuse to play that game. Yeah. If you want to
talk to me about a specific issue. Yes, let’s
talk about it. And if you can if you can not
just make the case for your argument.”
Ideally, I mean, this is asking a lot, but like
steel-man, a counterargument, just to prove to me
you’re not in this to have a shouting match. Okay,
then let’s have a conversation. But as soon
as you apply — and I think I’m borrowing from
Paul Graham on this, of Y Combinator fame —
but the more labels you apply to yourself,
the stupider you get. I think
that’s true. The more you calcify
your thinking and/or just absolve yourself of
thinking, which is a luxury. It’s deferring. Which
is a luxury, if you want to be an outlier in terms
of the impact you have, the happiness you can
achieve, that is a luxury you can’t
afford is absolving yourself of thinking.
Or maybe it’s a bell curve. Who knows?
Maybe, like the people who completely
don’t think and the people who think the
most are the happiest. Who the hell knows?
I think a lot of it’s probably out of
the box. Because there are, I’m sure,
people listening who are going to be like,
“Wait a second, this guy can’t be any happier.
What kind of alien is this guy?” How much of
that do you think is out of the box? Just.
Hmm. Your code versus a cultivated —
Derek Sivers: Do you know Sonja Lyubomirsky?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Derek Sivers: Okay. You know who she is?
Tim Ferriss: Nope.
Derek Sivers: Oh, she wrote one of those books on
happiness. After I read Stumbling on Happiness, I
went, “Ooh, that was good. That was a good book.”
And I went to go find other books on the subject.
So she wrote a couple of books on happiness. She’s
been studying happiness for decades.
Tim Ferriss: Sonja Lyubomirsky. I’ll
find it. Put it in the show notes.
Derek Sivers: So she said in one of
her books that that her studies have shown that
most people’s happiness is 50 percent DNA and
out of their control, and the other 50 percent is
in their control. So the best we can do is just
control that 50 percent, you know?
Tim Ferriss: It sounds like
you’re a stoic — closet stoic.
Derek Sivers: Oh, I am.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Yeah.
Minus the minus the -ism.
Derek Sivers: You talked about Stoicism a bit and
I was like, “Pfft. Ancient crap.” And, and then
finally in 2010, I read A Guide to the Good Life.
Tim Ferriss: William Irvine, I think.
Derek Sivers: Whoa! Oh, my God. I thought
this was just me. Like, this is everything
he’s talking about. This is the way I’ve been
thinking since I was a teenager. I don’t know
why I picked it up. Maybe. I suspect — I found
out years later that the Dale Carnegie book
called How to Stop Worrying and Start Living.
Tim Ferriss: Just as a side note, I’ve read
that book multiple times. I just went into my
Kindle recently to look at my Kindle library,
mostly to see like whether it was 70 or
80 percent of the downloaded books that
I hadn’t read. And I came across that book and I
thought, you know what? This would be a good time
to revisit this. They are very overlapping.
Derek Sivers: I just read a couple of years
ago in Wikipedia or something that that
book was basically spouting stoic values.
Tim Ferriss: Makes perfect sense. It’s a
great book, by the way, folks. How to Stop
Worrying and Start Living by Dale Carnegie.
Derek Sivers: It was on my grandmother’s
bookshelf, and I read it when I was 16. Up
until two years ago, I would have said that
all the things that Stoicism says, I’ve believed
these things since I was a teenager. I thought I
made these things up! I thought this was just me
being weird. This was my weird approach to life.
But then just two years ago,
I saw that Wikipedia entry.
Tim Ferriss: You got incepted by Dale Carnegie.
Derek Sivers: Inception. Yeah.
But point is, I’ve been thinking that way
since I was a teenager, and it wasn’t until
the age of 40 that I read an actual book
on Stoicism. “Whoa! This is how I think!”
But that being said, yeah, I think it’s
healthier to watch out for whenever you
find yourself wanting to jump all in to an -ism,
even if it’s just a book that you just read. If
you find yourself blindly saying, “All of this,
this is me, this is how I’m going to live now.”
Tim Ferriss: Unless you have the self-awareness
or meta-awareness to say, “Okay, I’ll try all this
stuff on for size.” This is like me putting on a
suit to see what happens. But not like this is THE
TRUTH in all caps. “This is who I am.” Identity.
Derek Sivers: Right! That’s totally different!
That’s pluralism versus monism.
Mon- is one — to say monism is this.
It’s mystical. The number one is somewhat
magical and mystical. One love, one world,
one answer, one way. It’s very
appealing, this idea of one.
And it’s very upsetting to think that no, no, no,
there are many answers and they conflict and you
can believe conflicting things at the same time.
So sorry, I accidentally skipped your skipped
answering your question about was it
either am I this happy or why am I
this happy or why do I think I’m this happy?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. This researcher who wrote
the book after Stumbling on Happiness said
50/50, and then I dragged us into Stoicism.
Derek Sivers: I got the lucky
roll of the dice, the DNA dice.
But also, there’s another thing I’ve been
doing since I was a teenager, that I found
out has another name too. So for my whole life,
I very often will open my diary and just put
everything into there. I write what happened
today, but also the things that I’m thinking.
Whenever I come upon a belief that, to me, feels
like a disempowering belief — something that I’ve
said — my own beliefs that sound disempowering
to me — like “I hate it here. I can’t do what
I want here. I need to go somewhere else to do
what I want.” — I’ll just keep it general like
that — then I’ll stop and ask myself, “Wait
a minute. Is that true? That sounds like a
disempowering belief. Let me push back on that.
I think that belief might be holding me back.”
So I’m constantly doubting everything
I write, doubting everything I think,
doubting everything I say. And questioning it.
Tim Ferriss: And you do this in writing?
Derek Sivers: Yeah, I do this in
writing. My fingers just fly.
So later I found out that this is similar to
Cognitive Behavioral Therapy. I’ve been doing
this for decades and now I just found out
what it’s called. So I just recently read a
book on Cognitive Behavioral Therapy and went,
“Oh, this sounds like what I’ve been doing.”
Tim Ferriss: So also in the "All roads lead to
Rome" type of metaphor: CBT, as I understand it,
largely based on many stoic writings.
Derek Sivers: Oh, right! That makes sense. Yeah.
It’s the conclusion of the big arc I was on — the
whole “Useful Not True” super-skepticism thing.
You asked me last week, “How do you
change your beliefs? How would you
recommend somebody do that or how do you do it?”
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, how do you translate that into
durable behavioral change? Right? Because it’s
one thing to intellectually recognize this is
a disempowering belief. It would be much
better for me to hold this other belief.
It’s one thing to achieve that, and quite
a different thing to implement that latter
belief in a way that changes your behavior.
Derek Sivers: You stack up evidence. So first,
just writing in my diary. About “I need to believe
this.” I think I need to believe that the place
I’m in right now is a good place to be, not a
bad place to be. I think that would be a more
empowering belief for me that I can use where I am
to do what I want, not need to escape where I am,
for example. So then I need to
just stack up evidence of this.
Once you’ve decided on the belief that
would be better for you to hold, well,
you can always find evidence to support any
belief, right? You could just stack up evidence.
We’re social beings, so talking with friends
about it and asking their thoughts on this.
Or telling them “I’m starting to think this.”
Friends, if they care about you and they support
you, will often give you other evidence to
support the belief you want to have. Saying,
“That’s a good point. You know my friend
Tracy, such and such or this and she had
this happen. So yeah, I think you’re
right on with this new idea of yours.”
Friends support it and then you start to
internalize it more. Maybe it takes a few days.
You take some baby steps to put it into action
or a big giant leap to put this into action.
Like some crazy things I’ve done in my life
too. I do cut off some options in my life
as a giant leap. We can talk about that if you
want. Small actions or big actions. You can take
the action before necessarily internalizing it.
Tim Ferriss: Fake it before you make it. Do it
before you believe it. Act as if.
Derek Sivers: “I should sign up for
college.” And you’re just like, “Right. I should.”
(imitating typing) “Oh, my God. I just did.”
Even before you’ve convinced yourself
you can sign up that little form and
take that first step to take the action.
I’ve done a lot of things like that in my
life where, to support a new belief, I
will take an action first. Then we all
have the desire to be congruent with the
actions we’ve taken. “Oh, look, I’m this
kind of person now. This is my belief now.”
Tim Ferriss: So for folks listening who may
find it helpful to have a structured way to
cross examine their own beliefs and maybe take
an opposing stance and then gather evidence.
There’s something called “The Work” by Byron
Katie, which is very much this. And I found
personally very useful. Super, super useful.
You teased — you weren’t sure whether
to open the door or not. Giant leaps. So
with the understanding that what you do is not
necessarily what you recommend for all people.
Is there an example of a giant
leap that might make for a story?
Derek Sivers: Yeah. I renounced
my US citizenship in 2011.
Tim Ferriss: That’s a big one.
Derek Sivers: I deliberately burned the
ships. So I have to explain this metaphor because
I found that most people haven’t heard this tale.
But we’ve all heard of burning the bridges. So
you burn the bridge when you destroy a friendship,
a connection with somebody, the bridge between
you and another person. But to burn the ships
is a reference to a Spanish conquistador
that had headed off with three ships to
South America somewhere. And when he landed, there
were thousands of Aztecs waiting to kill them,
and they only had a few hundred men. Of
course, I’m messing up the details here,
But he turned to one of his men and said, “We must
not retreat. Burn the ships. The men need to know
that we cannot go back. We must go forward.”
So I wanted to challenge myself to go forward
and not go back. After 40 years in
America, I felt like, all right,
I spent the first 40 years of my life here, I
want to spend the next 40 out. But what I found
is whenever things got tough, I kept wanting
to retreat back to my comfortable California.
So I thought, “I need to
burn the ships.” So I did.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, I’m laughing because there’s so
many rabbit holes we could go down here. I’m going
to I’m going to use my my creative license as the
host of this podcast to avoid most of them. But,
are you glad you did that?
Derek Sivers: For years,
it was one of my biggest mistakes in life.
Tim Ferriss: It made it hard to
visit family and friends in the US.
Derek Sivers: Yeah, anybody asks me about it,
my advice was always, do not do it. In
fact, it still is. Somebody just asked
me last week, I was like, do not do it.
Kevin Kelly had this wonderful saying:
“The best option is the option that gives you
the most options.” And under that wise advice,
I think that no, you should not renounce your US
citizenship because it’s cutting off options.
A lot of people seem to want to do it for tax
reasons. You need to look through that thoroughly.
I did not do it for tax reasons. And in fact, my
taxes went up after I renounced because most of my
income is still U.S. sourced. So now that all
gets taxed at flat 30 percent rate instead of
before it was part of a bigger picture. So yeah,
my taxes went up and it reduced my options.
So there was something scary that happened just
a few months after I renounced my citizenship.
My ex, her dad was on his deathbed and we
needed to quickly get on a plane that night.
But I didn’t have the visa. So I went to
the US embassy to get a visa quickly and
they rejected me. I was devastated because
they just hand you a slip saying, “No, you’ve
been denied for a visa. Next!” The slip says,
“You may not reapply. This decision is final.”
Tim Ferriss: Useful Not True.
Derek Sivers: I challenged that that
rule. I was like, all right, I think somebody
just made that up. I’m going to go back and
reapply anyway. So I went back with a mountain
of evidence and luckily they granted me a visa.
Tim Ferriss: Mountain of evidence for what?
Derek Sivers: I was living in Singapore at the
time. My good friend from Bangladesh said, “Derek,
this is your first time being refused. I’ve been
refused like five times. Look, here’s how to do
it. You can’t just go to the embassy and say, Give
me a visa, please. You have to show a mountain of
evidence that your life is in Singapore. Tell them
about your cat, that you have a job, that you have
this, that you’re on the board at this company,
that you’re speaking at National University of
Singapore. Show them your two year rental.”
Tim Ferriss: You’re not a flight risk, right?
Derek Sivers: Not a flight risk. So I went back
with the mountain of evidence and a letter
from the doctor, from my ex’s dad saying,
“Please, he only has a few days to live.
Please allow them to come back.” And so I
was granted the visa, but it was scary as hell.
So I think that people are often overconfident
thinking like, “Hey, I’ll just renounce
my citizenship and it’ll lower my taxes.
I can go back anytime I want.” But not true. I
always say “No, no, no, once. Once you renounce,
you might never be allowed in that country
ever again. That is not your country anymore.”
So I do not recommend it.
Tim Ferriss: I would say in
general, not too broad a brush, but the U.S.
frowns upon people who renounce citizenship.
Derek Sivers: Yeah, I’m always aware that I might
never be allowed back in ever again.
Tim Ferriss: What is another example
of a giant leap? Anything come to mind?
I mean, that’s a huge one for sure.
Derek Sivers: Moving.
Tim Ferriss: Was it worth it for you? So you said,
I wouldn’t recommend this to most people. And I
know we we live looking forward and not behind.
We can’t change the past as far as we know now.
Derek Sivers: 12 years later, since doing it, it
did come in a little handy in COVID times where —
I will skip some family drama details but — there
was a big big pressure on me to move to America.
And I was able to just say, “Nope, can’t do it.
Don’t want to. Don’t have
to. Can’t.” And so finally,
after 12 years, it came in handy for that.
But no, to me, that was a huge thing.
Tim Ferriss: Any other giant leaps?
Derek Sivers: Selling my company
came in an instant moment of clarity.
Life is weird when you can hold multiple
philosophies in your head at the same time.
This is the whole thing I was talking about
with “Useful Not True” — that
no beliefs are true, so you can
hold them all in your head and just look at them.
Here’s one belief that says you should stick it
out when the going gets tough.
You need to stay in there.
There’s another belief that says the
rewards to effort ratio is off — that
I’m spending so much effort and getting
so little reward — that you should stop.
You can just hold these in your head and look
at them as as paths you could go down, as
philosophies you could follow.
And then ultimately you just pick
one — or you craft one from a hodgepodge,
a piecemeal from the from the other bits.
In that moment, I was feeling really frustrated
with my company. I’d been doing it for 10 years.
I was feeling done like a bit like like
somebody who’s been painting a mural for
many years or writing a novel for many years
and just you put the last brushstroke on,
you write the last word and you go there,
think I’m done. That’s how I was feeling.
But somebody could have argued, “Okay, go take
a vacation and come back and get back to work.”
But I played off some different
ways of thinking about it.
And in that moment, while driving down Pico
Boulevard in L.A. while on the phone with a
friend, I was like, “That’s it, dude, I
think I’m done. I’m just going to sell
the company.” And I decided in that moment.
It wasn’t fully congruent yet. It was just
one of many options. But that night I went
and called three companies that had been
asking to buy my company and I told them yes.
Tim Ferriss: Was there a feeling or a meal or
something your friends said that triggered that?
Derek Sivers: He just asked me a bunch of
questions. He challenged the things I was
saying. He basically did the cognitive
behavioral therapy with me. He was pushing back
on everything I was saying, challenging it.
So, for example, I said, “I’m sick of
having all this responsibility. I don’t
want to have to do this and have to do that.”
He said, “You don’t have to do anything.”
I said, “Yeah, I have to pay my taxes.”
He said, “No, you don’t.”
I said, “Yes, I do. You have to pay your taxes.”
He said, “No, Derek, you need to understand
this. You don’t have to do anything.”
What’s the dude on Power of Now that
went sat on a park bench? Do you
remember who wrote Power of Now?
Tim Ferriss: Eckhart Tolle. I never read
the book, but heard good things about it.
Derek Sivers: I unfortunately tried to listen
to it on a long drive and don’t do that. It’s
hazardous. He’s got very soothing voice.
He starts out the story saying that at
one point he just went to go lay on a
park bench and basically just sat there
for a couple of years doing nothing.
It’s a reminder that you don’t have to
do anything, that everything is a choice, even
paying your taxes, you don’t have to. There will
be consequences if you don’t. But let’s always
be clear that you’re choosing to do it. You’re
choosing to pay your taxes because you’d rather
not have the consequences. You’re choosing to pay
your employees. You’re choosing to go into work.
None of these things are things you have to do.
I think he pushed back on that a few times.
Ultimately my value system is such that I most
value personal growth. And it felt to me like
I’ve been doing this thing for 10 years, so the
bigger learning, growing opportunity for me
right now is to do something else. It wasn’t
a matter of up or down. It was just different.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. So let’s segue from personal
growth to mentors because many people have had
mentors. Many people seek mentors. Many people
pine after mentors. And if if they could only
get a hold of person X and have a cup of tea or
a coffee, pick the brain, have a meal.
How would you suggest people ask
mentors for help?
Derek Sivers: Here’s
what I do. I have three mentors.
Anytime I hit a little dilemma in my life,
I write a really good description of my dilemma
before I reach out to them, because I don’t want
to waste their time. My mentors are VIPs. I
don’t want to waste a minute of their time.
So first I write a really good description
of the problem and then I summarize it. I
summarize the context, the problem. I summarize
my options and I summarize my thoughts because
I've got to make this succinct. I don’t
want to send somebody a 20-page-long email.
I have to make this as succinct as possible.
Tim Ferriss: What is that in practice look
like? Half page?
Derek Sivers: Yeah,
half page. Bullet points for everything
instead of paragraphs. As succinct as I can.
Then before I send it to them, I try
to predict what this person would say.
Tim Ferriss: Each of those three?
Derek Sivers: Right. What that mentor
would say. I know the way this guy
thinks. I’ve read all his books. I
know the way we’ve talked a lot. I know what
he would say. So then I internalize that.
Then I address those points that I’m predicting
they would say I’m going to address those in
advance again, to not waste their time.
Tim Ferriss: So when you say address them,
what do you mean by that?
Derek Sivers: Kind of like how I
said something five minutes ago, when you asked
me a question like, “Can you give me an example
of that? Or how do you know this?” I knew you
were going to ask that. So here’s my follow up.
I’ll address those in advance again so as not to
waste their time. And then again, one last time,
I try to predict what they would say.
Tim Ferriss: You have an answer ready for
whatever they might come back with.
Derek Sivers: But I include it
in the initial summary of my situation.
After I’ve done that whole process, I don’t need
to bother anymore because the answer is now clear.
Because I’ve just done the work of summarizing
everything and imagining what they would say.
So the punchline is, the truth is,
I haven’t talked to my mentors in years.
And one of them doesn’t even know I exist.
Napoleon Hill talked about the
mastermind. Imagine Abraham Lincoln is
there. What would Abraham Lincoln say to you?
I also get a lot of emails from people saying,
“I need a mentor. Will you mentor me? How
do I find a mentor?” And this is my answer.
It’s all in your head. It’s about the
summarization of your situation, thinking
of it from another person’s point of view.
You can predict what this person would say
if you’re a fan of their books and their podcasts
and their talks, you know what they would probably
say. So do it yourself.
Tim Ferriss: Who is the
person who doesn’t know you exist?
Derek Sivers: It was Tyler Cowen. Oh, I
just emailed him two weeks ago to say thank you.
Tim Ferriss: Thanks for your years of service.
Derek Sivers: For his continued inspiration.
And he sent me back a tiny little thanks.
Seth Godin is one. He knows I exist. We don’t
talk that often, but I very often think,
“What would Seth Godin say?”
Tim Ferriss: He walks the walk.
Derek Sivers: Very much so. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Not as common as you would hope.
Who’s the third?
Derek Sivers: It’s actually
changing. I don’t know right now.
Tim Ferriss: Keith Richards.
Derek Sivers:
Bjork.
Tim Ferriss: Chucky Cheese.
Derek Sivers: That’d be great. That’s
thoroughly useful. A fictional
person can be your mentor.
Like, what would Jesus do? Like people do that.
“I’m not sure what to do. What would Jesus do?”
That’s a perfectly good mentor.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. And
I think a lot of people would agree with
you. And for those people who might wonder,
I actually do something very similar.
Derek Sivers: Okay. Can you tell?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, absolutely. I try to spend time
with people I admire and aspire to be more like
in some capacity. Right. Because I do think you
become the people you spend the most time with.
So to bring up a name that we’ve already
brought up, I think actually a lot about
Matt Mullenweg because he’s very calm in
almost all circumstances, not all. I know
what the handful of things that bother him.
He’s very, very calm and measured and good at
perspectival knowledge taking taking alternative
positions, taking the counter position on his own
thoughts, his own opinions, his own goals.
And so I often think when I get dysregulated
or upset about something, I’m getting
wound up. I’m like, “What would Matt do
in this? What would Matt say to me if Matt
were in my shoes? What would Matt do?”
I’ve also done that in writing exercises where I
actually just sit down with my older self who has
figured it out. So if if I’m talking to a version
of myself who’s 10 years older or 20 years older,
who has figured this out. What might that older,
wiser version of me say? And I just write out
the dialogue. And by the end, I’m like, “Huh!”
It doesn’t always give you some magic solution,
but it is astonishing how often that will give
you some type of clarity or maybe a relief
that helps you to cling less strongly
to whatever the challenge or problem or
question was that you had in mind. It’s really
it’s really remarkable. So I do something
very similar, I guess is what I’m saying.
Derek Sivers: Sometimes even just asking. I
get emails about once a week where somebody asks
me a big question by email and then at the end
they say, “Actually, you don’t even really have
to answer this. Just honestly, asking you the
question helped me get some clarity. Thank you.”
Just the act of opening their email client and
saying, “Okay, I want to ask
Derek Sivers this thing.”
Tim Ferriss: If I intend to reach
out to a mentor about something,
I still go through the exercise of trying to
crystallize my thinking so I don’t waste their
time, even if it’s a really close friend. I don’t
want to be lazy. And I don’t want to ask them
something that could be resolved with five minutes
of Googling or five minutes of introspection.
Whenever I go to anyone I want to be able to
say, “Here’s a situation. Here are some of
my assumptions. Here’s what I’ve already tried.
I’ve tried A, B, C, D, and E, and I’m not quite
figuring it out.” And then followed
by a super specific question.
But asking the mentors around your imaginary
table, and doing that homework, I think, is it’s
something that I do and I recommend to everyone.
And there is some selfish motive here. I would
like to have fewer than several thousand
emails a week that come in with like,
“How can I launch my book? Please tell me.”
Derek Sivers: I’ll admit I actually got
oddly shy two minutes ago when you asked
me who the third one was, because actually,
it’s been you! I didn’t want to bother you with
things. I was tempted. I’ve got your phone number.
I could have just texted you. And I’m like,
“No, hold on and I’ll just do it first.” Never
mind. I didn’t ask you. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Well, thank you.
I think about you, Matt —
It’s funny you mentioned Seth,
because Seth would be on a short list
for me as well of people who really
think and — more than think — question the musts,
the shoulds, the have-tos. I’m like,
wait a fucking second. That’s nonsense.
You know, I feel like you’re very good at
that. So that’s part of the reason I’ve read
your first book so many times.
Derek Sivers: Now I’m all shy.
Tim Ferriss: We should do two things. We
should get a slight refill on the Scotch
and then maybe talk about games.
The games we play. All right.
Getting good at games, things of this type.
So a little bathroom and then Scotch break.
We’re back. Cool. And for people
wondering, we just came back from
our bathroom/break/scotch-refill.
This is very similar to a lot of our
conversations. Like it’s not that different
from a lot of our conversations. But I do
appreciate how much thought you give
to deliverables for the audience.
Makes a big fucking difference. Honestly.
Derek Sivers: The greater good. I think about
making it interesting conversation for you.
But then there’s how-many-people that listen?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you’re good at holding both.
Derek Sivers: Looking at you, but I’m thinking of
them. No offense.
Tim Ferriss:
Wow. We could. We could unpack that for a while.
Derek Sivers: All right. You and your euphemisms.
Tim Ferriss: All right,
dark mirror. Here we come.
Uh, cheers, man. Cheers. So nice to see you for.
Derek Sivers: Oh, thanks again,
Matt. I don’t know why we think Matt’s there.
Tim Ferriss: Matt’s got the fuzzy hat on,
otherwise known as the boom mic. (Sip of
Scotch.) Oh. Oh, it is nice. All right.
So we’re all playing games, right? And I
think it’s a matter of knowing which games you’re
playing outside of some basics. You got shelter,
you got food, you cover some of the lower rungs
of Maslow’s hierarchy of needs. Beyond that,
we’re all playing different games. So
knowing which games you’re playing,
then choosing the game you want to play,
these are these are important topics.
Why don’t I just hand the mic over
and let you talk about how you
think about this kind of thing playing games.
Derek Sivers: Something that might seem strange
about me — that sometimes people say — that I
seem weird because of the choices I make in life.
Tim Ferriss: You’re pretty weird.
In fairness, it’s a compliment.
Derek Sivers: I try to explain that it’s just
because for 10-15 years, I was playing a certain
game. I was trying to be successful. I wanted to
be famous. I wanted to be a successful musician.
I wanted to be rich in that way. And I did it. And
in my mind, to my own standards, I won the game.
And when you win the game, say you’re
playing Settlers of Catan or Monopoly or
poker with friends. When you win the game, what
do you usually do? Stop playing! You say, okay,
let’s go do something else. I won the game.
So even with, say, addictive video games,
So have you ever played Stardew Valley?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Derek Sivers: Oh, don’t.
Tim Ferriss: I probably shouldn’t.
Derek Sivers: It’s adorably addictive. Yeah.
So my ex grew up on a farm, and Stardew Valley
is one of those little farming games where you
tend to your crops and then you get animals
and you get money for selling your crops.
Tim Ferriss: I think the story behind this
game is also very interesting.
Derek Sivers: Made by one guy
with a passion for many years.
Tim Ferriss: I believe there’s a lot
of additional context to that that we don’t have
to unpack now. But people people can look into
it. It’s a fascinating, fascinating backstory. But
yeah, don’t play it because it’s digital heroin.
Derek Sivers: If you want to play a great game
that is also non-greedy, I found it because it was
recommended on a list of like No Bullshit Games
that don’t ask you for more money. Once you’re in,
you just pay your $9 or something like
that up front and then you’ve got the
game forever. So that’s cool. Let’s say actually
if you are looking for a new game, it is a great
game. Stardew Valley is wonderful.
But it’s so wonderful that my ex
and I got really into it. She played it for
something like 400 hours. The little clock shows
you how long you’ve played, and at a certain point
she had done everything. She’d made every dish,
planted every crop, caught every fish, done
every favor for every villager, she was done.
But yet there was this yearning to keep
playing because she was so good at it.
The temptation to keep playing, even though the
rewards are done, isn’t that the definition of
addiction? Continuing a behavior even
though it’s not rewarding you anymore?
So to me, that’s what making money is.
It’s a game that I’ve decided to stop
playing because I've got enough.
But this could apply to anything.
Somebody who wanted to be a successful
musician. Gotye. (singing) “You didn’t
have to cut me out. Now you’re just
somebody that I used to know.” That guy.
One hit wonder. Gotye from Australia.
That was his stage name. He did a beautiful
thing: He retired that stage name. He’s like,
“There did it. I had a massive number one hit.
I don’t want to keep singing that song for the
rest of my life. There is no more Gotye.”
So now he’s just back to his legal name and
he’s the drummer and singer in a band called The
Basics, and he retired Gotye. He stepped away.
Jacinda Ardern, the most recent prime minister
of New Zealand, after six years felt that she had
had enough and she quit instead of going through
the process of running for re-election. She quit
mid-term and she said, “That’s enough.
I’m feeling full. I’m feeling spent.”
Serena Williams, I think you know, quit
instead of going longer than she should
have. She quit after 27 years and like, that
was enough. She hit her point. That was enough.
Cameron Diaz. I suddenly, after watching
There’s Something About Mary with my kid,
I said, “I wonder what ever happened to her.”
And I looked up and saw that she was the fifth
highest grossing actress in America. The highest
paid Hollywood actress over 40. And then she’d had
enough. And so she just quit to do other things.
Tim Ferriss: I should interview her. She would
probably not say yes, but those stories
are fascinating to me. Because people are
just like, “Yep, good. Bye.”
Derek Sivers: I think there’s
something really admirable about the personal
challenge of making yourself do something else.
Most of us stay in the game for too long. So
I really admired that Jacinda Ardern did that,
when politicians are known for trying to
hold on to power as long as they can, right,
until they’re forcibly removed, kicking and
screaming. I really admire that she did that.
I was super, super influenced by Felix
Dennis’s book called How to Get Rich.
Tim Ferriss: Which I just
have to say it’s definitely
not suitable for family listening, but the audio
book is exceptional. I think it’s Roy McMillan,
who’s the narrator, and I know that because I
looked it up because I was so impressed by the
narrator. But he talks about coke and whores.
Derek Sivers: Yeah, that is one specific thing.
But that’s so wonderful that he admitted that.
Tim Ferriss: It funny for that reason,
right? Because he’s so candid, in a way
that you would not normally find in most
books like this. So unapologetic
on other things. The whole thing
is is refreshingly unusual. I enjoyed it.
Derek Sivers: I love that book. And I read
that at a key time. It was right about the time
that we met like 2008. I was just selling CD Baby,
and I was suddenly, you know, coming into more
money than I could ever spend in a lifetime. And
just about that time, I read Felix Dennis’s
book, How to Get Rich. And in it he had this
quote that I got ready for our conversation here.
He said, “If I had my time again, knowing what I
know today, I would dedicate myself to making just
enough to live comfortably as quickly as I could,
by the time I was 35. I would then cash out
and retire to write poetry and plant trees.”
I read that at a key fork in the road moment
for me where I just sold CD Baby and had a ton
of money. I was like, “What to do now?” And I
read this book from this filthy rich old man
being entirely honest, and I thought I
should just learn from his experience.
So I took his lesson to heart and I said,
“All right, Felix Dennis said if he could
do it all again, he would just retire and write
poetry and plant trees.” And I haven’t planted
any trees yet, but it’s kind of what I’m doing.
So if what I’m doing seems weird, it’s because I
took his advice to heart and I’ve quit the game.
Most people go by the the inner compass that says,
“I’m really good at this game,
so I should keep playing.”
But I think we should all entertain the
idea that we could say, “I’m really good
at this game show, so I should stop playing.”
Tim Ferriss: Hmm. I’m excited to dig into this
because there are so many facets that I
want to hear your thoughts on. So first,
I want to pick up on something that I
did not know, although I guess looking
at your history makes some strange
sense, but wanting to be famous.
You strike me as someone — and I mean this in
a very neutral way — and this is also why I
asked you the other day at lunch, what makes you
emotional? — you strike me as a very thoughtful,
but in some ways unemotional person. Well, not in
a bad way, but you don’t have volatile emotions.
Derek Sivers: No.
Tim Ferriss: You don’t have strong displays
of emotion. And that could be a misread. I admire
that about you, by the way. Just the general,
at least from the outside. Maybe it’s like the
duck on the pond, right? Calm on the on the top
and kicking like hell underneath. I don’t know.
But you have thoughtful, almost serene
contentedness. Almost all the time that I
interact with you. That is my perception.
Derek Sivers: That’s true.
Tim Ferriss: And that’s remarkable.
You seem to have a very, very, very low need
for external validation. That’s my perception.
Derek Sivers: Yes, it’s true.
Tim Ferriss: So that makes it odd
or for me to hear you say, “I want to be
famous” because I’m like, what do you get
out of fame if that’s your constitution?
Derek Sivers: You and I have thought for
hundreds or thousands of hours about the concept
of success, what it means to be successful.
I’m 53 now. I have spent almost 40 years or let’s
say 35 years thinking about being successful.
Just a few weeks ago in a podcast
interview, somebody asked me,
“What’s your definition of success?”
And I said “To me, it’s just achieving what
you set out to do. That’s your personal success
for that thing. I think it’s very individual.
And he said, “Nothing to do with
what other people think of you?”
And I went, “What other people think? No! What?”
And he goes, “Yeah. I think for a lot of people
they would define their success
through the eyes of others.”
I was like, “Why? Why would anybody?”
And he said, “Wait, you seriously
have never considered that?”
Tim Ferriss: Wow, he’s barking up
the wrong tree. Yeah, he’s got the wrong guy.
Derek Sivers: In 35 years, I had never, ever,
ever for a single millisecond considered
success as something that would be seen
through someone else’s eyes. To me,
success has always been hyperpersonal.
Tim Ferriss: Yes. How does fame fit into that?
Derek Sivers:I think a little bit like
the things that you talked about being
competitive, like your personal tendency.
As a teenager. I was like, “I want to get famous.”
Not like as famous as Prince. Prince was like a
musical role model for me. He was my musical —
Tim Ferriss: Incredible musician.
Derek Sivers: Yeah. I didn’t want to be that
famous. But, like, I don’t know, Brian Eno.
That’s a good fame role model where it’s not
like he’d get hounded walking down the street.
That was driven by a competitive drive.
More like, “Let’s see if I can do it.”
Just with that spirit of like, “I think
I can do that. I want to try doing that.”
And it was also feeling that what I was
doing musically was valid and worth hearing.
Tim Ferriss: Someone was asking me
recently because I was describing
how excited I was to see you. We haven’t
hung out in so long. It’s been so fun.
Derek Sivers: 12 years.
Tim Ferriss: God, it’s crazy
because we also interact virtually.
So I was describing to someone
that I was excited to see you. And they asked
what made you interesting or — I don’t think
they said unusual. “Oh, what’s what’s he
like? What’s what’s so interesting about him?”
And I said, well, part of what’s interesting is
I don’t think I’ve met anyone who has the
combination — outside of you — who has the
combination of seemingly no need for external
validation, yet being a good performer. Right?
You were a ringleader in a circus, right?
Musician. You’re really good at imitation: voices,
etcetera. You seem to enjoy performing.
Almost everyone, and I do mean almost
everyone — and I’m only saying almost because
it seems too absolutist to say everyone — but
it might be everyone who I know who is a really
good performer — it could be comedy. It could be
acting, It could be fill in the blank — had that
drive to become excellent doing that because they
they loved or needed (or
both) external validation.
It’s a very uncommon combination,
which is why I was asking you about it.
Derek Sivers: So maybe it is because I
had that life shift where it’s like I
did it to a certain point. I didn’t
get as famous as I thought I could,
but I was successful enough. Like I bought
my house in Woodstock with the money I made
touring. By my own definition, I
was a pretty successful musician.
Then just at the time that that was getting
boring, I accidentally started CD Baby and I
just threw all my attention into serving the
musicians. So I think that flipped something
in my head where it’s like I no longer need the
attention for me. I no longer I don’t need any
more attention. I don’t need any more validation.
And now I don’t even need any more money. I
really don’t need anything from anybody.
But yeah, you’re right. I still am socially
skilled. I know how to get on stage and talk.
Tim Ferriss: Good at it. Really good at it.
You’re a combination of elements that I don’t
usually see together. It’s very very rare.
Derek Sivers: Am I blushing?
Tim Ferriss: You’re blushing.
It could be the Scotch.
So the next question that
comes to mind for me is whether you have
always been a satisficer — to harken back
to The Paradox of Choice terminology from Barry
Schwartz, or if you’ve ever been a maximizer.
And the reason I ask is because framing games
in the way you have, which is once you’re good
at a game and you win it’s only natural you would
stop playing that game is, to me, the the sequel,
the spirit, the essence of a satisficer.
There are people, however, who, let’s just
say they want to be a grandmaster in chess.
Like "This is my game. I win." That is a win
on the road of additional wins and mastery
to strive to become the best in the world.
Or there’s another option, which is someone who
has played a game for so long. Let’s just say it’s
finances. They finally “win” in quotation marks.
They no longer need to work to meet their needs,
but they have played one game for so long they
don’t know what other game to play. And that
Paradox of Choice anxiety leads them to continue
playing the same game. I know so many examples
of people who have won. They’ve won the Oscar.
They’ve made a gazillion dollars, done whatever.
They don’t have the same love perhaps
they once did for that game, but they
continue to play it because subconsciously or
consciously they do not know what else to do.
So I know this is a hodgepodge of a question, but
it leads back to, I guess, the first, which is
have you always been a satisficer?
Derek Sivers: So the the third category
of people that don’t know what else they can
do, that’s the category that — by my values — I
want to physically pick them up and put them
into a different scenario. I think it’s just,
objectively, “You need to change now. You need to
shake it up in order to live a full life. Yeah,
you need to see the world from
different perspectives. You’ve
been doing the same thing for too long.”
That a belief of mine, which means it’s
not true. But I believe that you should.
Tim Ferriss: Just because it’s not true
doesn’t mean it isn’t valuable.
Tim Ferriss: Right. It’s useful.
It’s useful to believe that you shouldr.
Tim Ferriss: I should put a different way.
Just because it can’t be proven is true doesn’t
mean it isn’t valuable. I know we’re going to
get into some semantic rathole here, so continue.
Derek Sivers: So those people, I think absolutely
should. Somebody needs to kick them
out of the nest, shake them out of
their habits. Go do something else.
The only celebrity death that upset me
was Kurt Cobain. All the others seemed to be
like, okay, they’ve made their contribution
to culture and I appreciate them. But
like, I wasn’t eagerly awaiting George
Harrison’s next album, you know. But Kurt
Cobain, fuck, he had so much more to give,
but he was miserable. And some like that. Maybe
not to that extreme, but let’s just use that as
the farthest end spectrum on this kind of person
that says they’re miserable doing this thing,
but they feel like it’s all they can do.
Those people I just want to like, you know,
physically restrain them and pick them up and
put them into another environment to show them
you can do something else. It’s a bigger world.
Tim Ferriss: Or like, you’re good enough. Go to an
ashram for two years. You can always
come back. You’ll be fine, you know?
Derek Sivers: Right? Yeah.
But just imagine the joy of even simple
manual labor. What is at the end of the movie
The Last Emperor. This guy has been through this
big giant arc. And at the very end of the movie,
he’s just, you know, picking weeds in a garden.
Because he used to be the emperor, but the Chinese
Revolution assigned him to just be a gardener now.
And he kind of found his peace with it. And we
all have different versions of that we could do.
Like for the most part, for the last 12 years,
I’ve just been a full time dad here in New
Zealand. I know there are other impressive things
I could have done, but this meant the most to me.
Tim Ferriss: Impressive is
such bullshit external, right?
What what really drove that home for me is I’m
an enthusiastic student of history. And I read
Genghis Khan and the Making of the Modern World.
Tim Ferriss: Great book. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Really good. Especially the
first half or so, is really exceptional. But
I realized because they mentioned Alexander
the Great in that book, and I realized.
Alexander. It’s kind of like Madonna. It’s got
one name. I don’t know that dude’s last name!
Do you? And, like, I’ve polled audiences. Not
a single person has ever raised their hand.
I’m like, okay, this is ostensibly the
greatest conqueror the world has ever known,
given the constraints and technology at the time.
Can’t even name his full name. So just like that,
impressive. I don’t know. I’ve just become
less and less kind of concerned with that.
Derek Sivers: There were some
subquestions in that last one.
Tim Ferriss: I can rewind. Which, by the way, is
totally developed skill. That’s not something —
This is after doing a lot of podcasts.
Derek Sivers: Dude, I noticed from our
walking down the street or walking
through a forest and talking,
you would pick up on a few words that I said
in passing. Two days later, you were like,
“Let me ask you some more questions about that.”
I was like, “How the fuck did you remember that?”
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally trained.
Yeah, yeah. Which is wild.
So I was asking you maximizer versus being
satisficer. Have you ever been a maximizer?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Derek Sivers: So just like you can’t preach
minimalism to somebody who hasn’t felt the pain of
having too much stuff. They need to feel the pain
of having to look after too many things and
having a cluttered house and they go, “Ugh,
I need some minimalism.” You can’t just
preach it to them. So I think it’s the
same thing with maximizing and satisficing.
Satisficing is a lifestyle for me now — something
that’s deeply internalized because I’ve felt
the pain from trying to maximize decisions
and spending hundreds of hours trying to find the
best this or best that or make the best decision.
I write in my journals so much, so many
pages on something. And in the end,
I felt the pain from doing this. Now I
need to learn how to say good enough.
I put that into action because
of reading Paradox of Choice.
I said, “Okay, I need to do this. He’s right.
Dude is smarter than me. I’m going to do this.”
So yeah, I just internalized it and I did it.
When I catch myself in a moment, like shortly
after that I moved to Portland, Oregon, shortly
after reading The Paradox of Choice. It’s a
pretty car-focused city. The CD Baby office
was out in the far northeast and I needed to
get a car. And I had just recently read Paradox
of Choice, and I said, “I’m going to give myself
two hours to choose a car maximum.” And so, yeah,
in two hours I did quick research for 30 minutes,
went out to some car lots, looked at a few
options, and went, “This one is good enough.”
I loved that car. Yeah. Was it the
best possible choice? No. Who knows?
Tim Ferriss: Well, for you it was.
Minimizing regret. Two hours.
I don’t know who the hyper-effective
person is you mentioned earlier, but
choosing that there are just a couple
things that you care enough about. Like,
I am glad that Josh Waitzkin
is not a satisficer. I am glad
that he went all the way down the rabbit hole.
So I’ll tell you, I don’t think he would
mind that. So I believe that it is Josh who
actually said that to me where he’s like,
“I basically focus on like one or two
things. And then the rest, good enough.”
Derek Sivers: Right? Because he’s so
intense about those couple of things.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. You have to.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah he’s another one who
walks the walk in a big way. Have you met Josh?
Derek Sivers: No. He’s a role model for me.
Tim Ferriss: You guys would hit it off.
Derek Sivers: He’s one of those invisible
mentors. Not officially, but I loved his book,
The Art of Learning. And I’ve listened to his
interviews, and I really admire him. And so I
have many times wondered, like, when I’ve hit
some kind of dilemma or situation, like, “What
would Josh Waitzkin do in this situation?”
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I mean, no social. Doesn’t
read email. I mean, there are so many conventions
that he bocks. It’s really inspiring.
Derek Sivers: Yeah. And so that’s kind
of one of those, you know, nobody
cares what you’re bad at things.
I’m sure there’s a bunch of stuff that Josh
Waitzkin is not good. But it doesn’t matter.
Tim Ferriss: Good enough.
Derek Sivers: But have I always been
like this? No. I think I had to feel the pain.
Tim Ferriss: So what what did you use to maximize,
at any point?
Derek Sivers:
10 years ago I overthought where to live. I was
feeling very, very free after I sold my company.
What do you do if you can do anything but you
don’t have to do anything? And where do you go
when you don’t have to be anywhere and you
can be anywhere? It’s too much freedom.
Tim Ferriss: It’s too much.
Derek Sivers: It’s a complete blank
slate with no restrictions at all. I wasn’t even
in a relationship. I was just completely unbound.
So I spent far too long in my diary thinking
of every possible place on earth I might
live and why. I spent hours reading about
places that I still haven’t even visited,
but I learned all about them. I even know
what it takes to move there. And you know,
the naturalization law of becoming a citizen
there and the steps to becoming a resident
there and the pros and cons of living there.
And I’ve read books about it, but still haven’t
been there. I did that for many countries.
So that’s that’s something that was like 10
years ago. I was still maximizing that. And now
here we are in New Zealand where the longest I’ve
ever lived somewhere in my life is right here.
I used to always move around every two years and
I’ve been right here in Wellington 11 years now.
Tim Ferriss: Parked-up. That’s wild.
Derek Sivers: It’s good enough.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I mean,
there’s a lot to be said for it.
I want to say for people listening also that you
might think, good Lord, like this is pretty head
in the clouds, one-percenter stuff in the sense
like “That doesn’t apply to me. That’s crazy.”
But I would just point out that — God, I got this
from a documentary. It wasn’t Helvetica, which is
a great documentary about type font typefaces and
fonts and so on. Really cool doc. There’s
another one about industrial design,
and there was an expression in that that stuck
with me to this day, I think it was from a
company or one of the founders of Frog Design,
but I could be getting that wrong. And it was:
"The extremes inform the mean, but not
vice versa." Something along those lines.
It’s like when they’re when they’re designing,
say, garden shears, they’re not designing for
the average person. They’re designing for the
edge cases. So it’s like the the old paraplegic
woman who needs to use it from her wheelchair. And
then like the 350-pound bodybuilder who like can’t
brush his teeth because his arms are too big.
Okay. If you design for those those edge cases at
opposite ends of the spectrum, you cover everyone.
But if you design for the average person,
your error rate is going to be really high.
And so I’ve thought about that in so
many different domains. So in this
case, I’m saying you’re providing,
from a socioeconomic perspective, an edge case,
broadly speaking. But there are principles in
that exaggerated state that are easy to see,
that are harder to see in some of the cases
that are closer to the middle of the bell curve.
So we’re exploring these things and the experience
of this over-optimizing and Paradox of Choice
and burnt cycles on something like location,
I think everyone listening can find
somewhere, right? They can find some place
where they’re over optimizing in that way.
Derek Sivers: Thanks for framing it like that.
Sometimes I feel guilty speaking candidly about
something that’s actually going on with me,
if I know that it doesn’t apply to everybody.
Whatever I do publicly, I try to
make it for them. It’s not so much
my personal expression as it is me
giving back. The world’s given me a
lot. This is what I do to give back.
But it’s a nice reminder, the way you just framed
it. It’s kind of like Felix Dennis writing his
How to Get Rich book. Dude was worth 600 million
when he wrote that. He didn’t have to write that
book. And he wrote about his extreme case. But
for me as a small fry reading it, it was really
useful to read what somebody in an extreme
situation did, and how he made his choices,
or what he regrets, and what he would do.
Derek Sivers: Oh! You know what I’ve been
meaning to ask you forever?
Derek Sivers: So when people ask the
question, “What would you tell your younger
self?” what’s the real question there?
Because I unfortunately have taken that question
literally too often. You asked me seven years ago
when I said, “Women like sex." Because to me
at that moment, that’s what I wanted to tell
my younger self. I felt like culture sold
us this story that women don’t like sex,
that it’s something men want and women
reluctantly give. And so for most of my life,
I was trying to be considerate, so I was not
entirely sexless, but mostly. And it wasn’t
until like my late 40s that it was like, “Oh,
my God, women like sex. Nobody told me this. Oh,
my God, this changes everything.” I had more sex
in the last three years than the rest of my life
combined because this this newfound insight.
And so what would I tell my former self? Fuck,
yeah. That’s what I would tell my former self. But
that’s just me! I don’t think that’s the question
Tim Ferriss: The question is, “What
advice would you give me?” Right?
Derek Sivers: You?
Tim Ferriss: No I’m saying:
when someone says, “What advice would you give
your younger self?” what they’re really asking
is “What advice would you give someone who is
not where you are, but who wants to be where
you are?” I think that is the translation.
Derek Sivers: What advice would you give
someone who wants to be where you
are, but is not where you are? Like
how to get how do I get where you are?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I think that’s what
people are generally asking, right?
Because I don’t give a shit what you
really — what your younger self would do. They
care about what they would do. Rightly so.
But the answers are actually very different
if I’m being honest. Right. The answer that
I would give to some person whose specifics
I don’t understand are very different from
the advice I would give to my younger self.
Because in my case, having a history of some
very extreme depression and near suicide in
college and so on, my advice would be related
to self preservation and recommending
perhaps certain tools like meditation,
like consistent exercise, which I which I had on
some level but I think I could have tripled down
on consistent exercise, perhaps supervised
psychedelic therapies. Et cetera. Which
don’t apply to everybody. They just don’t. I think
some of those things might apply to some people.
But if someone’s really asking like, “How do I
achieve X? How do I have the life that you have?”
Number one, I would say you don’t
actually know what life I have.
You get the highlight reel and you get what
I share in podcasts, but you don’t have the
full picture, so be careful what you ask for.
Number two, I don’t understand the assumptions
embedded in them wanting X, right? Because
if their assumption is — let’s just say and
you and I have seen this in ourselves and our
experience and the experience of many others,
“Once I have X amount of money. All my problems
just disappear.” Like the vapour of mist hit by
the rising sun, all my problems just vanish.
That is an incorrect assumption, right?
But if somebody’s just asking that at a Q-and-A at
SXSW, you don’t have the time, you don’t have the
space to unpack all of that. So any answer
you give is going to be hopefully helpful,
but it could be really misdirecting in a way.
Derek Sivers: It’s funny the nature that these
questions come to us is usually one
question asked, one answer expected.
But if you think of the physical metaphor, just
imagine that you are somewhere on Earth right now.
Say you’re sitting in somewhere in Argentina.
And a phone call comes in and says, “How do I
get there? How do we get to where you are?”
I think, “Well, depends where you are. Are
you in Brazil? Are you in France?
Are you in Finland? Where are you?”
But that would take a back and forth that we don’t
have. If somebody asks you one question — “How do
I get where you are?” the only honest answer is,
"Well, it depends." But that’s not a soundbite.
Tim Ferriss: You clapped your hands. Is the
question you wanted to ask, “What question
I think people are asking when they ask?”
Derek Sivers: Yeah, because I’ve always wondered,
how do I do I think of that question? I
keep getting that question all the time
on podcasts. Damn it, this question
again. What I would tell my younger
self? It came up again just two weeks ago.
Tim Ferriss: It comes up a good amount.
Derek Sivers: Yeah, I need a good answer
for that, without the snarky saying,
“I don’t understand the question.”
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it’s not a bad
question. It’s just so context specific that it’s
not just unhelpful but I think dangerous to give
too broad a response. To use your geographic
metaphor, you just send somebody off in
completely the wrong direction.
Derek Sivers: Go east!
Tim Ferriss: Go east! Take two of these. Call me
in the morning. Oh, shit. I’m in Antarctica. Sorry
about that. Yeah, I thought you were in France.
Derek Sivers: Can you go east from Antarctica?
How do they do directions in Antarctica?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I mean, unless you’re at
the South Pole, you could give those.
I suppose it gets a little tricky. But
the good news is there’s pretty much nobody
there. So you’re not going to be giving too
many directions to people. They’re
going to be at some type of base.
I’ve only been once to Antarctica, actually
recorded a podcast in Antarctica in an outdoor
tent with someone and a field biologist
and photographer, which was super fun.
All roads lead to Matt Mullenweg. I owe him
thanks yet again for getting me down there.
Derek Sivers: It was one of my
favorite episodes of yours — that
conversation with Matt in Antarctica.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah. You know, I actually
I recorded two. I did one with Matt and I did
one with I want to say her name was Sue Flood,
but I could be blanking on the name. This amazing
photographer. Wow. Two podcasts in Antarctica.
Derek Sivers: Yeah, that was
fun. That’s why I was asking.
Tim Ferriss: If I know Matt at all, I
know that there’s probably some Scotch
involved with that as well.
Derek Sivers: I like how my son
spent time with you in Wellington and wanted to
ask you questions about Antarctica. And instead
he had a more pressing question,
which is, "What is it like to be 16?"
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. “What is 16-year-olds do?
How do 16-year-olds walk and behave?” Do you
want to explain the context?
Derek Sivers: We took him to
see John Wick: Chapter 4.
Tim Ferriss: Turns out that
in addition to to biosecurity in New Zealand, the
people at the movie theaters are really strict.
Derek Sivers: That was off point for New
Zealand. New Zealand is a wonderfully casual
culture. Formalities are very uncommon
here. But that was a weird moment of
strictness where they wouldn’t let my
11-year-old come in to see John Wick,
but we were determined to get him in.
Tim Ferriss: Even though he’s seen
and memorized all the John Wick movies.
Derek Sivers: Uh, huh, yeah, he’s seen all the
previous ones. He’s seen much worse. He’s read the
Saga comic books. Oh, yeah. Highly recommended,
by the way. Saga. Best graphic novel.
Anyway, so he’s seen it all. So I went
in to try to get the tickets while my son
and Tim were out on the street and he said,
“Can you teach me how to act like I’m 16?”
Tim Ferriss: "How 16-year-olds behave.”
We were fortunate we had some sort of zoo
animals in the form of three other 16-year-olds
nearby. And so he was trying to mimic it.
And I was like, "Okay, you’re very smart,
you’re very verbally intelligent." He’s a
very clever kid. But the body language and the
energy is not at all matching a 16-year-old.
So we've got to work on this a little bit. He
had pulled the sleeves of his sweater.
He had his hoodie up. And I was like,
“I’m not sure that’s helping. It might be
hurting. You look very conspicuous.” And
then he pulled down the sleeves to make his arms
look longer. But the proportions were all wrong,
so he looked kind of like E.T. And I’m like,
“I think you’re drawing more attention than you
want to draw.” But the whole thing was very cute.
Derek Sivers: He means so much to me that it’s —
I’m proud of myself that I didn’t
cry when I told the story about the
cardboard box in London. I almost did.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. And your answer when
I asked you what makes you emotional,
was “anything related to parenting."
Derek Sivers: Yeah.
If you guys have ever seen or go see the song
“Papaoutai” by the Belgian musician Stromae, it’s
basically this. It was a hit single in France and
Belgium, and there’s a great music video for it of
this guy who’s basically being a bad dad. And when
he and I watch that video together, I always cry.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you’re kind
of tearing up right now.
Derek Sivers: Yeah. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Derek Sivers: Yeah, it’s serious.
Tim Ferriss: Which is. Which is new in my
experience of Derek Sivers. Seeing this.
Why do you think that is?
Derek Sivers: It’s
so important. The stakes are — (crying)
Well, yeah. Shit. New experience.
Got to collect myself for a second.
The stakes are so high, that if you do this right,
it passes on — (crying)
Wow. What should?
Tim Ferriss: We’re not in any rush. Zero rush.
Derek Sivers: Hmm. It’s funny also collecting
my thoughts on how to say this. I don’t have
to explain it much. Nobody’s asked directly.
If you do this right, it passes
on for many generations —
A kid that’s raised really well can pass
on that generosity of spirit, you know?
Somebody that’s raised ignored might pass
on that scarcity of spirit, you know?
(crying) Holy shit, I’m not doing this for the
media. This is not like trying to be a captured
moment. Holy shit.
Um.
Yeah. There we go.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Thank you for answering that.
This is new, also, I’ll say for folks.
What a gift that you have something that you
respond this way to.
Derek Sivers: It’s the only thing I do!
You know, it’s funny, my ex, after we broke up,
said like, “I’ve known you for so many years.
I’ve never seen you get mad. I’ve never seen you
cry. I’ve never even really seen you get upset.”
I’m like, “Yeah, I just don’t.
Really I’m a happy dude.”
And, yeah, this is the only thing (that makes
me cry), but it’s like it’s not an upset cry.
It’s like, holy shit, this is such a big deal.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Derek, we’ve covered a lot.
I’m just saying, I don’t feel like we need
to cover anything more. Is there anything
you’d like to to say? Any requests to the
audience? Anything at all before we wrap up?
Derek Sivers: Yeah, I know you’re going to
say this is crazy, but still, to this day,
my currency — the thing that matters to me
more than money — (obviously many things do) —
I still really like meeting people.
I just recently went to India. I went
to Chennai and Bangalore for 10 days and I sat
down and talked with 50 people in 10 days. I had
one- to two-hour-long conversations with
50 people. And a lot of these 50 people
are people that I’d been emailing with
for years. Like they just contacted me
out of the blue because they read my article
or they read my book or they heard a podcast
and they emailed to introduce themselves. And here
it is 10 years later. Now I’m in Bangalore and we
finally meet and it was so damn rewarding.
And similarly I went to Helsinki, Finland for
the first time and what do I do? I email say
“Who do I know in Helsinki?” And there were
a number of people that had emailed over the
years to introduce themselves. And soon I’m
like sitting naked in a sauna with some dude
that emailed me because, you know, he read
my book. This matters to me more than money.
It’s the reason I do a podcast like this. I’m
clearly not selling anything. I don’t have
a big ask. But I really like it when people
email to introduce themselves, especially if
it’s not coming with a loaded question like,
“What would you tell your younger self?”
Or, “What should I be doing with my life?”
When people just introduce themselves, it
means the world to me. It’s really cool to feel
connected with people from around the world —
to know that I have friends in India or have
friends in Nigeria or friends in Finland. That’s
my favorite thing, hearing from strangers.
So honestly, like my website, which I made myself
as a static HTML website speaking of our earlier
tangent, if you go to sive.rs — just send an email
and introduce yourself. That’s my surprising ask.
Tim Ferriss: To other domains point to that?
Derek Sivers: It used to be sivers.org
Tim Ferriss: You still have that I assume.
Derek Sivers: Yeah, I’m keeping that
forever. But that’s my minimalism
thing. At one point I looked at
that like “.org — hmmm...”
Tim Ferriss: Where is .rs?
Derek Sivers: Serbia. Republic of Serbia.
One of my favorite tech sites is lobste.rs.
Tim Ferriss: Wait, what the
hell is lobste.rs about?
Derek Sivers: Oh, it’s just it’s just a random
domain name they got. But it’s programmers and
sysadmins talking tech and it’s fun. It’s like
Hacker News minus the business. Oh, I hope I
didn’t send a bunch of traffic their way.
But yeah, I looked at the “.org” — I used to
have sivers.org and I looked at it, like, “I’m
not really an organization, am I? Those four
characters aren’t really necessary, are they? I
think I could reduce those. So yeah. sive.rs”
Tim Ferriss: Thank you, Derek. So nice. So
good to hang out, have some Scotch and —
Derek Sivers: And make me cry. Holy shit.
Yeah, That was my first time in, like
three or four years.
Tim Ferriss: I’ve never seen you cry. Yeah.
Wow. Exclusive to the Tim Ferriss podcast, folks.
Derek Sivers: I’m just trying to help out my
friend, you know, get him some more views.
Tim Ferriss: Yes, more views. I’m all about the
views. It’s so good to hang, man.
Derek Sivers: You
too.
Tim Ferriss: Thanks.